I have been looking forward to this
podcast for a long time. Gentlemen,
this is a about as cool
pod get for me as a fan.
This is like one of my favorite ones
because Randall Carlson and Graham Hawk
Handcock together and your new book,
magicians of the Gods,
is it out officially everywhere.
It's published on the 10th of November.
Fantastic. Of the U s all
over the u s and uh, Randall,
you guys together is just
so exciting to me because a,
I know you guys spent a lot of time
together and you were working together on
just this current project.
We did a fantastic research
trip across the channel,
scap lands of Washington state,
which Randall has been walking the walk
on for decades and he just showed me the
absolute irrefutable evidence
of cataclysmic flooding
in that, in that area.
And it plays a very important
part in the book. UH,
North America was the epicenter of a
global cataclysm between twelve thousand
eight hundred and eleven
thousand six hundred years ago.
And when you see it through Randall's
eyes and you get it immediately. This,
this whole subject in,
you know,
since you've been on my podcast
and you've been on the podcast,
is something that comes up. I mean, I'm
not kidding, four or five times a week,
someone will grab me and ask me,
when is Graham coming back on again?
When's Randall coming back?
And when I tell people that you
guys are coming on together,
the people who start
freaking out. So, you know,
we've been saying before this that
people are taking time off work there.
They're having little viewing parties.
So two people out there,
we're just excited as you are. So,
um, tell me what's been going on.
So tell me the Washington state thing.
Tell me what you guys saw and,
and what picture evidence and,
and what was revealed.
I'm going to pass that
one to Randall first off.
Um, well we, uh, we're
basically traveling.
What we did was we traveled from Portland
to the twin cities and what we did was
essentially followed the,
the southern margin of the great
ice sheet for the most part.
And what we were looking at was this
evidence that the whole ice sheet had
undergone this massive
catastrophic sudden meltdown.
And basically what we could,
what we saw in the landscape was
evidence that was oceanic level currents
flowing off the ice sheets.
In fact, the, the, um,
the geologists that have been looking
at this use a term called spur drop,
which was originally a
contrived to, um, it's,
it's a, uh, a million
cubic meters per second.
And they originally came up with a
to talk about, or ocean currents,
like the Gulf stream and so on.
Um,
not realizing that down the road it was
actually going to be applied to currents
that were flowing over the land.
Um,
but that's what we were looking
at was spelled that word as it's,
it's named after the, uh, the
scientists that first, uh,
came up with the concept.
It's s v e r Drup spur drop.
It's 100 million,
I'm sorry, a million cubic
feet, cubic meters per second.
Um, whoa. Which is very
difficult to even envision,
but when you see it on the
landscape, I mean, for example,
there's a place called the
chemists prairie that Ronald
took me to what you see
these kind of ripples in the ground
and they look a little bit like current
ripples on the beach, you know, but
actually they are current ripples,
but they're 50 feet high and hundreds
and hundreds of feet long and there that
receding flood left those ripples on that,
on that landscape.
Then above the town of when Archie,
there's a gigantic boulder which
didn't come from we're Nachi.
It weighs 18,000 tons and it got there
in an iceberg the size of an oil tanker,
which grounded against that side of
the valley. The floodwaters receded,
the iceberg melted away and it left this
humongous boulder there and actually
there's thousands of them.
Thousands of these gigantic Boulder's
just scattered across the landscape of the
Pacific northwest northwest,
and it all speaks of this cataclysmic,
horrendous, humongous flood that
happened to have Sunday, 200 years ago,
18,000 tons to these.
You just threw out some giant numbers
that the the meters per second and the
eighteen thousand eighteen
thousand tons is a ton,
is 2000 to 18,000 tons is 18,000
to thousands so it's 36 million.
If you want, I can pull up some
emails or something of that order.
Let's just say really fucking Mig.
I made an enormous,
an enormous thing and the fact
is that there was just one,
it would be spectacular,
but there's thousands of them and,
and they're all just washed away by this.
When the,
when the ice caps suddenly melted down
and we know now that that happened
because of the impact of
several fragments of a,
of a giant comment back 12,800 years ago
released a huge flood of meltwater and
that melt water carried. It was
jostling with icebergs, huge icebergs.
And many of these icebergs had had rocks
in chain within them as Glacio glacio
ice moves, it snatches up and in
chains rock and keeps it inside.
There's a name for them.
They're called glacio radix.
And so they're in these icebergs and
the icebergs are jostling against each
other.
And the flood is ripped up.
Whole forest bites roots and there's mud
and there's rubble and it's rumbling in
it's, and you see it all
on the landscape up there.
And this is all carbon dated to this
time period. The dating is very secure.
Very, oh my God. If we
look here at the image now,
this is not from the catastrophic
flood we're talking about obviously.
But interestingly enough,
this was a hundred year flood
that happened in Georgia
back in 2004 and what we
had was a a flood plane that got uh,
over top for the first time in decades
and it left these current ripples here.
And I just,
I use this slide to show what we're
used to under scale of phenomena that we
would normally see this kind of
phenomenon. So this is a normal,
very large major storm.
That makes sense.
This was hurricane Ivan when it
came through in 2004. It was,
they referred to it as a
hundred year flood. Right? So,
so this is a massive storm, but it's
nothing out of the ordinary really.
It's just, it's rare. It's
rare. What you'll see here is,
you know I've got a measuring tape here.
You're going to see the wavelength
is about three inches. The amplitude,
the vertical height of these things
is about three quarters of an inch.
And so these are all,
what we're looking at is all dry dirt
that has sand. You said it's been rippled,
it's been carried along in swept along
in this water that was over this flood
plain, which was two feet deep, carried
along. And as the water declined it, it,
it deposited this sand and then
rippled it as the final stages.
And we're looking at this, what year?
How long after the f the storm was this?
This was a week or two after the storm
because within a month this was all all
obscured by wind and everything.
So now just so you've got this
by comparison, we'll go to this.
This is what Graham was just
talking about. Camus prairie and,
and what you see here is there's ranches
out there and you've got this 10 mile
long field of these gigantic ripples.
And if you look up in the upper
left hand corner of the screen,
you can see some of these ripples.
They're like Graham said there,
they're a hundred to 300 feet in
wavelength and they're up to 50 feet in
amplitude. And the water that flowed
through here that that deposited,
this was over a thousand feet deep.
So this is fractal, this fractal.
You get it in the small scale in the,
in the first image rattle
showed the same phenomenon.
They are with a flood just two feet deep.
And then we come to this
humongous testimony to what
happened 12,800 years ago.
And it's easy to drive through it and
not really figure what you're driving
through. But once you, once you look
at it and realize what happened, it,
it really dilates the imagination.
So this must have been just an absolutely
enormous event when it happened and,
and really sun imaginable and unimaginable
and human beings lived through that
and it changed everything.
These they called extinction level events,
these global cataclysms
wipe the slate clean. They,
they change everything and they,
and they set a new order in motion.
A new audit follows that.
So the classic example is the extinction
of the dinosaurs. 65 million years ago,
that 10 dinosaurs into chickens,
you know,
and they were gone and it
opened the way for mammals. And,
and our distant ancestor is a
sort of 65 million year old shrew,
which was going nowhere until the
dinosaurs were wiped by a cosmic impact.
And then they began to
evolve. And, and here we are.
So dinosaurs became chickens and shrews
became human being charges for me to
imagine this. This is very hard to
be for me to wrap my head around,
but that we came from my shrew 65 million
years. All these harder. That's the,
that's, that's the, that's the story of
evolution. One can buy into it or not,
but that's the certainly mammals.
We're going nowhere right before the
dinosaurs were swept out of the, and the,
the point I'm making is that these events,
which are called extinction level
events, they reset the clock. They, they,
they make everything start again.
And,
and this is why what happened in
North America 12,800 years ago.
It's so important because that period,
the whole period was
12,800 to 11,600 years ago.
That period stands right in the
foundations of what we think of as the
beginnings,
the origins of civilization,
and yet mainstream archeology
and historians have not
taken it into account and
I don't blame them for that.
This is new information.
This is new science that's been mainly
published in the professional journals
since 2007 it's very
intriguing new information,
but we cannot any longer trust the
established model of the origins of
civilization since it does not take
into account an extinction level event.
Right in the foundations.
And that's why I say the House of history
appears to be built on foundations of
sand. Now, this hasn't been
adopted yet, but is it resisted?
Is has mainstream.
It is whenever you,
when ever you propose a
cataclysm of any kind,
it's a curious thing.
I don't know whether it's psychological
or something more sinister than that,
but whenever you, whenever you propose
that and present evidence for it,
you can be sure that you will be descended
upon by a furious crowd of critics
and the group of scientists,
more than 30 of them,
very significant mainstream scientists
who've been presenting the evidence for
the comet impact have had a fight on
their hands since 2007 but I can say with
confidence, and I detail it at length in
the book that they have won that fight.
Every criticism that's
been made at their work,
they have refuted and they've come back
with new evidence sometimes three or
four papers a year and it's a compelling
case and we can't ignore it and it
seems to me as a casual observer,
and I mean more cash,
probably more into it than
the average person, but no,
not even close to you guys that as
this evidence piles up like the,
the nuclear glass that they keep finding
it's about 12,000 that's one of what
they call the impact proxies.
See what we got to consider is
that we are looking at objects,
which might be a mile wide,
that are coming in to the atmosphere at
70,000 miles an hour and they are hot.
You know,
some people will remember comet shoemaker
Levy nine that hit Jupiter back in
1994 that was a small comment,
just two kilometers wide,
broke into about 20 fragments.
The explosive power of those
impacts on Jupiter was 300 gigatons.
Now let me put that into perspective.
The entire world's nuclear arsenal,
where it to go off at once
would be 6.4 giga tons.
So you're looking at something
beyond imagination. The, the, the,
the power of these impacts is absolutely
colossal numbers. Numbers don't do it.
Just imagine a world on fire.
Uh, wasn't changed forever.
The explosion that had Jupiter was about
the size of the earth to, right? No, no,
no, no. This was a
comment. I mean, politics,
the plume itself, the size of
the earth. Yeah, absolutely.
So we're looking at something that when,
when it happened it was,
what's the timeline around what,
what was the calculations around
somewhere around 11,000 years ago? Well,
there's actually a period this is, this
is an an rather than a single instant,
and that's part of the mystery.
First off,
there are the impacts 12,800 years ago
that causes this cataclysm centered on
North America, but global and global
temperature plummets. It, I mean,
people who talk about global warming
or today what, what happened,
the change in temperature 12,800
years ago is just stunning.
And this is undeniable,
this in depth.
The last time he was here with mainstream
scientific data that's irrefutable.
Absolutely. Core samples, ice core
samples, apps along those lines.
And they called the, just
call it the younger dryas,
and it's a 1,200 year period,
temperatures plunge at the beginning,
massive animal extinctions.
And then 1,200 years later,
equally suddenly temperatures
shoot up again dramatically.
And there's another series of floods
so that the period is 12,800 to 11,600
years ago. And I think, I
don't know if Randal agrees,
we're sure that the comment was the
cause of the first event 12,000,
800 years ago.
I think other bits of the comet,
we're responsible for
the second event as well.
I think there was an impact in ocean,
which through water vapor up into the
upper atmosphere caused a greenhouse
effect and created that sudden spike
in warming and that huge flood,
those two warming spike show up very
dramatically in the Greenland ice cores.
And I pulled these up I
think in the last meeting,
but it would be good to
reference it again. And um,
basically what you see here is warming
spike number one is here and warming
spike number two is here
and these were extreme,
you know,
we're talking about 10,
10 degrees centigrade roughly
in perhaps a year or two.
And this translates into about
17 or 18 degrees Fahrenheit.
So we're talking many
times greater than the,
the warming of the last century or two.
Um,
instantly basically just like that. And
this, this is this, this what we see here,
brackets, this, this
whole episode of this,
this period of transition from the
glacial age to this Nice Warm Holocene
interglacial age that we're in now.
And you know,
Graham brought up about how this sits
right at the very foundation of our modern
history. And if you look at whether
it's the dispersion of languages,
the beginning of agriculture, the first
cities, the domestication of animals,
what you see over and over again is the
same date showing up, you know, eight,
nine,
10,000 years ago.
And in this model that
we're describing here,
we're not really seeing the
genesis of civilization.
We're seeing the rebooting of
civilization in the aftermath
of these events. They're not the only
thing that makes sense. This is, this is,
this is what we have now.
We have now the data that makes sense
of what previously has been very
mysterious and unexplained evidence.
So for folks who are not aware
of both of your work, to me,
this is so fascinating because I've been
a fan of your, your books since God.
I don't, I mean more than
a decade. Right? What,
when did it come out in the nineties?
Well think of prince of the gods
which was published in 1995 which is,
which is 20 years ago,
and magicians of the gods,
the new book is the
sequel to fingerprints.
And I've written it because there's
just this massive new information that
changes the whole picture completely.
Uh, fingerprints of the gods.
I started reading sometime in the late
nineties and just became engrossed in it
and fascinated by this concept, that
civilization and as, as you put it,
that we are a species that has amnesia
and that just forgot what our past was.
But the two of you together is what's
so fascinating cause it puts this puzzle
together,
your obsession with asteroidal impacts
and these massive extinction events and
your knowledge of this ancient
architecture that doesn't make any sense.
And these ancient construction methods
that seem to differ and that the
timelines and for people who aren't
aware of the whole story behind it,
the erosion on the enclosure of the
Sphinx where where they made this fake has
thousands of years of rainfall erosion.
That doesn't make any sense because
the last time there was rain,
the Nile Valley was like 9,000 BC,
which is right.
Some around their ass really weave.
The climate of,
of of Egypt has been as dry as it is
today for about the last 5,000 years,
so you have to go back. You actually
have to go back to this period,
to this younger dryas period to get those
heavy rainfalls that could have eroded
the Sphinx in the way it is and I want
to pay tribute to the work of John
Anthony West and Robert Schoch from
Boston University because they broke this
story way back in 1992 and at the time
the Egypt illogical establishment of
course were furious that anybody dared
to suggest that the Sphinx might be
12,000 years old.
The Egyptologist said,
we know the Sphinx dates from 2,500 BC.
Actually,
one of the things I've done in this
book is look at what the Egyptology case
rests on. And it's a fairy tale. It rests
on nothing. It's kind of ideology. It's a,
it's,
it's their idea of how things should be
rather than any real factual evidence
that puts the Sphinx at 2,500 BC and
the geology puts the sphinx much,
much older. Now, the argument of
the archeologists at the time was,
and anyway,
the Sphinx couldn't possibly be 12,000
years old because if that was the work of
some unknown culture 12,000 years ago,
we're going to find lots of other
monuments around the world that had 12,000
years old and we don't find any.
Um,
well that was 1992 but now we're in 2015.
And the sight of God Beckley Tepi in
Turkey has been discovered with it's
gigantic
megaliths a deliberately buried time
capsule buried more than 10,000 years ago
and created 11 and a
half thousand years ago.
And if you can make go back the Tempe,
you can make the Sphinx.
We are finding the fingerprints of this
lost civilization popping up all around
the world.
Indeed on any archaeological site where
you can be absolutely sure of the dating,
the dating proves to be much older than
we have been taught by archeologists.
They recently discovered
a huge megalithic site,
40 meters underwater between
in the Sicily channel.
It's been underwater for
best part of 10,000 years,
which means that Megalithic site is at
least that old and maybe much older and
we can be sure about the dating
because it's underwater. Likewise,
we can be sure of the dating of Quebec
Lee Tapi because whoever made it
deliberately buried it,
sealed it,
and no later organic material got in to
contaminate the carbon dating record and
give falsely young. They didn't buried
someone else during that time period,
buried it, but somebody
buried it. They went to them.
We don't know when it was built,
but we know it's buried at least 10 to
12 the dates that are coming out of it
now,
the earliest dates now,
it's important to be clear that there's
much more of God Beckley Tepi under the
ground.
There's,
there's actually about 50 times as
much as has already been excavated,
which is under the ground
still and not being dug up yet.
They know it's there because they'd
been over the whole site with ground
penetrating radar and what they're seeing
is hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
of these huge 20 to 50 ton
t-shaped megalithic pillars
buried under the ground.
Somebody just as somebody went to
enormous lengths to create this site,
they also,
or somebody else,
went to enormous lengths to burry
it and actually got Beckley.
Tapi means potbellied hill in the Turkish
language and that whole potbellied
hill that covers this site was
artificially put there by human beings,
teams of men and women with buckets filled
with rubble and stones filling it in
and covering it up. So
strange. And there's no, no,
no guesses or theories as to why they
did this. Really not. There's the,
there's not,
it's just a fact that it happened because,
because archeologists and geologists
can tell from the nature of the material
that covers these pillars that it isn't
a natural sedimentation that they would
deliberately covered up what's going to
be satisfying to you guys too. Obsessed,
crazy man come together and your theories
lock in like puzzle pieces and ha ha.
Well you, you've got the right
word there because this is, man,
I even respect put my had up to
that as as I've, I've absolutely,
you've got to be a bit obsessed to
stick with somebody who I, you know,
I came in for an enormous amount of,
of criticism and flack when I published
fingerprints of the gods and I'm human.
It hurts when people say
really bad things about me.
But what I've learned is you just
have to persist. You just have to,
you just have to keep going.
Even if your ideas are shouted down by,
you know, the established holders
of knowledge in our society,
if you feel strongly enough about those
ideas, you've got to hang with them.
And I've hung with these ideas
for more than 20 years now.
And what we're seeing is just a massive
new evidence that that basically
vindicates the notion of a,
of, of a lost civilization.
See if I may say go Beckley Tepi um,
the earliest dates they've
pulled out of the ground now,
which they think is the foundation
of the site is 11,600 years ago.
And that is really significant because
11,600 years ago was the second episode
of cataclysm at the end
of the younger dryers.
And we know it was accompanied
by massive global flooding.
Is it possible that this
was covered up then?
And it wasn't covering up intentionally
by people that it was covered up as a
part of it was made after
the cataclysm was over. Uh,
an archeologist have a problem with this
because the site is very sophisticated.
It contains the world's first perfectly
north south aligned structure and you
can't do that without precise astronomy.
In fact,
they are huge astronomical implications
to the go back to the Tempe site.
The architecture is,
is massive.
And you see the problem archaeology
has is that up till now they've been
teaching us that megalithic
sites like this astronomically,
a megalithic sites like this,
our maximum of five to five
and a half thousand years old.
And suddenly we're looking at a site
which is far bigger than any other
megalithic site known in the world,
which is at least 6,000 years
older than any other known sites.
Or how do they explain this?
Our ancestors,
I supposed to have been just
hunter gatherers at that time,
nomads following the game,
not with a sophisticated
societal organization that
would have specialists who
had these knowledge, who had
the skills, who could put this,
put this work together.
So the fairy tale archeologist are now
telling about good Beckley Tapi is that
one morning a group of hunter gatherers
woke up somehow divinely inspired with,
with the complete knowledge of Megalithic
architecture and how to organize a
workforce on how to bring them to a site,
which by the way,
there's no water on that site.
And to put this whole,
this whole proposition together and at
the same time, exactly at the same moment,
11,000,
600 years ago,
we suddenly get evidence of
agriculture spreading all over Turkey.
It's like go Beckley Tepi as a center
of innovation and associated with it is
the birth of agriculture
in Turkey. Uh, and,
and to me this looks like
a transfer of technology.
It does not look to me like a group of
hunter gatherers woke up one morning
magically equipped with the ability
to invent agriculture and create a
megalithic site like this.
It looks to me like people who already
had that knowledge came into that area,
settled there and try to pass on their
knowledge to the local people and maybe
used to go back to the Tempe as a kind
of university or initiation center to
train and teach people in those skills.
That's what it feels like.
And another point is that that same day,
Dylan thousand 600 years ago is the date
that Plato gives us for the destruction
and submergence by flood of the lost
civilization of Atlantis. And up till now,
archeologists have dismissed the whole
Atlantis story and they regard it as kind
of pseudoscience,
although it comes from Plato.
But Plato said very clearly that this
happened 9,000 years before the time of so
long and so long lived in 600 BC.
So Plato is telling us
Atlantis went down 9,600 BC,
11,600 years ago.
Exactly the date of the second spike
of the younger dryas cataclysm.
If you're look,
you're at this graph,
we see random pull this sucker up close
to you so that you get a little bit more.
It's a, we can see here, these are um,
studies of sea level rise
at the end of the ice age.
And rather than it being a smooth curve,
which was the old model,
which you can see represented by the
dashed line, it's too enormous spikes.
And that second spike, it melt
what? There you see MWP dash one B.
That's meltwater pulse one B.
And you've got meltwater pulse one,
a meltwater pulse one B is dated
precisely to 11,600 years ago.
This is crazy. It's like everything
aligns, everything aligns the, that, the,
the nuclear glass that they're finding.
And then the core samples,
well that's all the same, run
the same test. What's the point
I wanted to make when we talk about these
objects coming in at 70,000 miles an
hour, they are packing an enormous
amount of kinetic energy and heat.
And when they hit the ground,
uh,
there are distinct products left in
the soil and that does include nano
diamonds. You can not, they're
created by the shock and the impact.
You can only see them, you know, that
under a microscope, that tiny, tiny,
tiny things and carbons
failures and the melt glass,
which is just basically
identical to trinity site,
which is the melt glass that you get from
nuclear explosions and they're called
impact proxies.
And there's a distinct layer of the soil
all around the world data to 12,000,
800 years ago,
which contains this stuff and also
contains the evidence of continental
wildfires burning.
And I think Randall might want to address
that issue of continental wildfires
and why they happen.
The, all these images are
beautiful bullets. Um,
note that most people are
just listening to this,
so if you're just listening to this,
those images that Randall put up on the
screen show these enormous straight up
and down spikes of the water level rising,
which has to be caused by
some ocean level rises,
which has to be because caused by
something extremely dramatic like that.
Just looking at that like, wow,
what happened there? Well nuts.
That's the melting of the ice sheets.
The sudden rapid catastrophic meltdown
or the ice sheets dumping millions of
cubic kilometers of water back into the
ocean basins and how those little dashes
on the bottom, the the numbers, how
many years do they represent like the,
that spike that goes straight up
and down though the largest spike.
How much time does that represent?
Well,
you've got to to hear that
basically represent the,
the margin of error in the dating.
The earliest version of it is the spike
you see on, right. The latest version
did you see is under on the left and it
varies between about 14 and 13,000 years
for the first spike. The second spike
is dating now too. About, like I said,
about 11,600 the,
the numbers across the bottom arth k
y r means thousands of years before
present. So you can see nine 10
that would be 10,000 years ago.
So essentially seems like our earth went
through like a thousand years of horror.
Thousand Years of hell. Uh,
it, it, it's, it's really
impossible to imagine what the,
what the world was like then
for the people who lived in it.
And I think it makes sense of why all
around the world we have a story of a
global flood.
This is,
this is not something confined to
the story of Noah in the Bible.
This is a universal story of a cataclysm
that changed the world and wiped away a
former golden age and left us with the
present order of things all around the
world. And secondly, all around
the world, and this is intriguing.
There is a universal fear of comments.
Now why should we be afraid of comments?
We see comments up in the sky. They
whizzed through, they have this nice tail,
they look, they look pretty.
Why should we be scared of them?
But every culture in the world has myths
and traditions that associate comments
with disaster. Uh, and, and I think
it's pretty obvious why, because this,
this comet impact 12,800 years ago was
remembered by the survivors and they
passed that memory down to their
children and their children's children.
And it's still with us today and it's
now we know based on something very real
well,
it seems like to me as a lay person with
all this evidence and all this evidence
that correlates, it's all corresponding,
it all seems to fit together.
It would seem that this would be something
that a lot of mainstream scientists
and archeologists would be extremely
interested in. Like why would they,
why would they try to ignore something
like the first thing they've tried to do
is to get rid of it.
This is often the case where new
information emerges that contradicts
established,
established theories.
And it's a strange phenomenon in science
because we like to think of scientists
as as rational and reasonable people.
But the fact is that when you get
very committed to a particular model,
to a particular idea, I think you start
to connect your own personality to it.
And any attack on that idea becomes an
existential, a tourniquet on you yourself.
How Sad. And it is an, it is
sad because again, and again,
what we see is the,
uh,
the new facts being dismissed because
they don't fit the existing theory where
in fact what we should
be doing is modifying the
existing theory to explain the
newly discovered facts.
And this is a,
this is a problem in the
whole history of science.
I remember when I first became aware
of that problem when I watched the
documentary and the mysteries
of the Sphinx where doctor
Robert Schoch met with,
uh, some archeologist in
Egypt. It wasn't Zoe Huw.
Asa was a,
a Western guy and he met with this guy
and they were explaining their theory
about the erosions of the Sphinx.
And he was laughing at it, me, me,
but openly
mocking yet, like what evidence
were, where's this evidence?
But it was the way he did. It was just
so riddled with ego. I was like, wow,
how could you,
first of all the concept of 11,000 years
ago when you start thinking about 11th,
that's a long time.
And what,
what evidence really would
be there other than stone?
It seems to me that it'd be very little.
I mean,
you've whatever fragments of
pottery, you'd be lucky to
find, we're lucky defined,
but looking for some massive evidence
that clearly shows beyond any shadow of it
outweigh. Here it is. I got, boy, you're,
you're asking for a lot from 11,000
years ago and you have something pretty
substantial right in front
of you and he's mocking it.
Exactly.
This is why I've,
I've come to view archeology and history
as a kind of more ideology really than,
than science. Um, there's, there's a,
there's an ideological view about how
civilization developed that we have this
long, slow, gradual,
politically correct rise
from the upper paleolithic,
from the hunter gatherers through
the Neolithic into the first cities.
And we go on and on and then we develop
technologies and here we are the apex.
And the pinnacle of this
whole story and Gosh,
we're so proud of ourselves and our
achievements and we think we're wonderful
and we praise and value our technology.
I've got nothing against technology,
but there's a hint of arrogance
in this. There's a hint of, of,
of pride that it was all about us.
And I,
I think that the,
once you start introducing this,
this new view of history that they
may have been an earlier civilization,
a high civilization which was utterly
wiped out by a global cataclysm,
why it contradicts that ideological
position and you find yourself in
ideological struggle with archeologists
and that's why, you know, sort of hub.
For example, if my book is handed
over to any archeologist to review,
they're just going to piss all over it.
They're not even probably going to read
it. They're just going to say, Hank,
what they say again and again,
Hancock is a pseudo scientist.
Nobody should listen to him.
That's there.
A system of attack is to first of all
devalue you so much that nobody will ever
listen to you.
And that's why I appreciate the support
of just real down to earth people out
there who are looking at this information
and finding the actually, yeah,
the story of history we've
been taught doesn't make sense.
And this new information does make
sense of it. Well, this new information
in my eyes, it seems, it's so
substantial and there's so much of it.
It's so,
so much of it fits together.
It's incredibly difficult to ignore and
much more so than when that documentary
and his finks was created.
So that was quite a while
ago. Charlton Heston was the,
the narrator to it. And, and, and
um, you know, at that time, uh,
we were sticking our necks out, putting
that, putting that information forward.
I was in that documentary as well.
But today things have changed. And,
and what I see is the,
the archeological mainstream in a
state of denial about this information,
they just don't want to
recognize it and absorb it,
but they're going to have to recognize it.
It's going to be forced
upon them, whether they like it or
not. It's so sad because you, you know,
you count on these people to
distribute the information, but they,
their egos get involved in things.
And if you've been teaching
something for a long time,
then it turns out you gave out master's
degrees on things that were completely
incorrect until lately. It's absolutely,
it's gotta be something else.
So though this sounds a bit
con con con conspiratorial,
I think the existing view of history
is part of a mind control system in our
society.
It's a,
it's something that we're presented with
that we take in with our mother's milk
and we're never supposed to question.
I think it's, if you control the past,
you do actually control the
present and the future as well. So,
but you mean if you have an absolutely
established narrative that you're
teaching and you're unwilling to look at
any possible variations to that, you're,
you're saying like almost
from an authority position.
We know what happened and we know where
we're going, but if you say, shit,
we don't know what happened,
then it's,
well we'll then who are you to
tell us where we're going? Exactly.
And it starts to raise questions
over everything, right?
Yeah. And we're kind of in this,
in this mode now where, um,
there's a,
uh,
a very large growing political agenda
around the idea that humans are the sole
cause of global change and that we're
the dominant force within this whole
process. Now here we come along
and we're saying, well, no,
there's actually been a forces unleashed
on this planet that really utterly
dwarf anything we've done yet.
What does that do to that,
to that paradigm?
You see that that's what I think what
we're coming down here to part of the, um,
the scenario now is that humans are
engaged in causing the sixth great mass
extinction as we talked about in
one of your, one of the previous,
and now we're coming along and
saying, well, wait a second.
Here's something from outer space that
has come in and caused the last great
mass extinction on earth.
And what's interesting I found is
that quite a number of the, um, the,
the scientists that have been in the
opposition to the younger dryas impact
hypothesis have been in the
forefront of pushing this,
this scenario of human
caused mass extinction and
blaming the extinction of the
great megafauna that died out
12,000 years ago on human hunters,
which I again,
we talked about that and I considered
that ludicrous that Paleo Indian hunters
using spears are going to
cause the extermination of
10 million woolly mammoths
before they could even reproduce,
along with 120 other species of Megafauna.
Well,
65% of all mammals in North America were
wiped out somewhere around that time.
Mega mammals, mega man, which
is over a hundred pounds in
body weight, essentially.
Yeah.
And actually more like 75 or 75 or 75%
of it was almost instantaneous load.
Right. I mean, it was over a course of
a very short period of time after time.
The scientists who have been
diligently working in this, in this
field since that they've
published their first paper in,
in in 2007 I've just brought out in
a new paper in the proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences,
July,
2015 where they're doing a statistical
analysis and all the sites where the
evidence comes from.
And what that tells us is that this is
what is referred to as an ISO crown.
This event 12,800 years ago.
It's not,
we're not looking at the effects of
a hundred or 200 years of um, events.
We're looking at something that happened
effectively in a single afternoon
across 50 million square
kilometers of the earth's surface.
Ooh, that gives me goosebumps
a single afternoon. Yeah.
All over the world.
Everything changes forever and
it's fucked for a thousand years.
Absolutely.
And then I'd like Randall to address
this issue of continent wide wildfires
because we do see this in the,
in the,
in the stratum that when you get this
super heated ejector coming down on and on
ancient primal forests,
consider the effect.
This is Marie Springs,
one of the Clovis sites.
And this is what the was known as the
Black Mat layer. Where's Murray Springs?
It's in Arizona and it's southern Arizona.
And it's near the Clovis site,
which is, um, New Mexico, um,
called the Clovis impact site. Well, no,
the Clovis site was where the one of the
first places in North America where for
human remains were found in association
with a extinct mega mammals such as
woolly mammoths. Um, and it's just
outside of Clovis, New Mexico.
They refer to them as the Clovis culture
because the culture was one of the
casualties of this climate impact.
The comment impact is often referred to
as the Clovis comment. Okay. Yes. And,
and many of these Clovis sites and
has been over 50 of them around now
documented over North America.
I think about two thirds of them
have this black matte layer,
which shows a very clearly in this image
now that black matte layer is black
because of the, uh,
considerable amount of carbon,
carbon soot that's in it. So
in other words, right there,
that's the evidence of your wildfires
is that this blanket of soot over the
continent that left this black matte
layer and below that black matte layer
you'll find extinct mega mammals.
Like here you see the Yellow Arrow there,
points to the black mat layer.
Now if you look up,
you'll see how it's more buff colored.
That was the color of all of this.
But the suit that was in that black
matte layer has dispersed and colored the
other adjacent layers.
But you'll notice the bones below
are the bones of extinct mammals.
The bones found above it,
our extent or still existing
mammals and net layer separates,
um, these, these,
these two domains of
extinct mammals and extent.
I have just a very clear line.
Yeah. And, and you can see it,
it shows up so clearly,
right to people who listening to this,
when we're looking at the original
image that Randall showed,
it's almost like an Oreo cookie.
Like there's a clean line and then there's
the white filling underneath. I mean,
it is as clear as day.
And what are we talking about?
Like how much fire and for
how long creates this area?
Well,
you're basically talking about burning
up a considerable portion of the bio mass
of North America in unglazed
glaciated North America to do this.
So you have the ice cap north of
roughly Minnesota and the south of it.
You have a heavily vegetated area covered
with primal forests and that's what
goes on fire.
And the reason it goes on fire is
because when these impact has come in,
they generate a huge amount of heat and
and what is called ejector superheated
ejectors throwing up into the upper
atmosphere and it falls down all over the
continent and it's sets the world on fire.
Oh God no.
At the procedure is so difficult in this.
It's a distance.
There's numbers that you guys are throwing
around and his concepts you throwing
around that. I just, I have to pause
when you're saying, well wait a minute,
I've got to try to fit this in somewhere.
But it's the whole,
the whole world on fire.
Yeah.
This is why I've written this
book because it's mind boggling.
It's mind boggling material.
And, and up till now,
most of the information has been confined
to the really rarefied scientific
journals. Very little of it has
got out into the public domain.
So one of the things I've tried to
do is to put this together into a,
into a form that's very accessible to
the general public because we all need to
know about this. This is our yesterday,
this is our background. This is,
this is where we come from.
The present order of the world
has descended from that moment.
And what is the mainstream explanation
for what we're looking at here?
Like how do they, how do
they describe this? Well, the
mainstream, the mainstream,
to me now,
it's Firestone and West [inaudible].
Yeah. And when Ronald says
Firestone in western Canada,
he's talking about some of the lead
scientists who have presented the evidence
for the younger dryas impact
because they have triumphed,
although they were attacked and sometimes
viciously, and frankly speaking,
sometimes dishonestly,
they were attacked,
but they defended themselves so well and
they kept on bringing in new data and
new information that actually now we
should be regarding their view as the
mainstream.
Yeah,
there are a few critics still hanging
in there who would like human beings to
have been responsible for the extinction
of all the the mega mammals and who
would, who you know, who
just are in denial about the
climate change at that time.
But there they're no longer
than mainstream. In my view.
One of the problems with the theories,
what you show the last time you were here,
these,
the evidence of these woolly mammoths had
died instantaneously and that they're,
they're massive fields of them that
something had to happen and ones with like
their legs broken just
bent over from the impact.
Like it's pretty clear something went
down and all of these pieces point
together and including looking at this,
which is just,
this is blowing my mind,
this idea of the world on fire just,
well there were some places that
apparently got spared like Australia or
something. Well, Australia actually
suffered a major mass extinction,
but earlier, probably from some
previous event, maybe 30,000 years ago,
but
just trying to figure out where to go
off and having a central Africa seems to
have been one of the places of refuge
because if we look at the distribution of
mega mammals in the world today,
where do we find the greatest
concentration in in Africa? Right? Well,
Africa has retained 90% of its
mega mammals from the pleistocene,
whereas North America lost 75% if you
go back to North America during the Ice
Age,
there was as many mega mammals,
if not more species than
there is in Africa today.
But what we see is that extinction
relates directly to habitat loss and
basically not much survived in
either north or South America.
North and South America were both severely
affected by these events and lost 75%
of their mega mammals. Eurasia lost
between, depending on where you go,
between 30 and 50% Africa
only lost about 10% of them.
And that's why you see so many
big animals still in Africa today.
And a lot of them,
I think probably disbursed from the
area around the great rift zone.
It seems like in a lot of
the areas actually where
we're finding early hominids
is,
is in that same area that seems like for
whatever reason it was spared somewhat
of the, the extreme severity that
the rest of the planet it's suffered.
It's an interesting situation because
when we look at the arguments of history
and archeology, very little of the
story is told in North America,
uh, in, as, as it's taught in schools
and universities today. You know,
they look at places like Sumeria in
Mesopotamia and ancient Egypt and further
down in South America, some of the,
the, the great cultures of the, of the,
of the Andes, but it's like North
America is missing from the map.
They talk about hunter gatherers coming
in here across the Bering strait and
there's still a, a dog, each faction of
archeology that wants to maintain that.
That just happened about
13,000 years ago. Um, and,
and that there was no human beings
in the Americas before that.
Although the mass of
contradictory evidence is
overwhelming that dogma as well.
It's obvious that the Americans were
populated long before that and those pop
populations did not only come
in across the Bering strait.
They came in in in other ways as well and,
and,
and then there just seems to be
nothing for a very long time and,
and North Americans kind of left
out of the story of civilization.
Well now I think we know why because
North America was at the heart of this
disaster.
It was at the absolute epicenter and the
slate was completely wiped clean here.
And that's what archeologists are,
are looking at.
They're seeing a wipe clean slate and
they think they're seeing the beginning of
something actually they're not.
They're seeing the movement on have
something after a horrendous disaster.
Wow. This, it's so
hard to wrap my mind around this idea
that for literally a thousand years,
the earth was just riddled with asteroidal
impacts and fire and nuclear winter
because of the Dustin mass extinction of,
gee,
it's so hard that the numbers that you're
throwing around the ideas behind it,
it's, it's, it's very difficult for folks
tonight put something in there
that brings it home in a way.
See this, um, event 12,800 years ago,
we know now it was caused by fragments
of a very large comet and the work
suggest that that comment may have been
more than 100 kilometers in diameter
originally when it entered the Minnesota
system. See, call it 62 miles. Right.
Big, big old comment. These comments,
they come in from deep space.
How big is the one that killed the
dinosaurs? Like five miles? Well,
that's thought to be 10 kilometers
wide. That that x miles, that,
that object ten six, six miles wide
at the times that, yeah. These things,
these things come in from deep space.
There are reservoirs of comets.
There's a place that
they call the Oort cloud,
which is just so far away that it's
almost impossible to imagine it,
but it contains trillions of
comments and often they're,
they're in stable orbits. They're not
coming into the inner solar system.
But as this solar system orbits
around the center of the Galaxy,
our galaxy is the Milky Way and we are
in orbit around the center of the galaxy,
our son, our solar system, everything is
in orbit around the center of the galaxy.
And that orbit is not only
in the plain of the galaxy.
Imagine a dolphin diving up and down,
coming out of the surface of the sea,
descending below, rising up again.
That's what the solar system is doing.
And those passages through the galactic
plane disturb the Oort cloud and they
send comments winging in
to the inner solar system.
Thank God for Jupiter,
Jupiter with its huge gravity is
the great protector of the Earth.
We should all wake up every day and say,
thank you Jupiter, thank you Jupiter,
that this doesn't happen too often, but
every now and then a comet gets past you.
But as God and comes in and enters the
inner solar system and the calculations
show.
This happened about 20,000 years ago
and that comment went into an orbit that
crosses the orbit of
the Earth twice a year.
We are still crossing the orbit of that
comment twice a year and there is still
a very disturbing amount
of debris within it.
It's called the Taurid meteor stream.
We've actually just finished our latest
passage through the Taurid meteor stream.
The earth passes through the story
of meteor stream twice a year.
It takes 12 days to pass
through it because the Tory
media story more numbers is
30 million kilometers wide and we orbit
at the rate of 2.5 million kilometers a
day,
so 30 it took 12 days to pass through
it and in the last 11,000 or so years
we've been lucky.
We've been passing through this
30 million mile wide stream.
We've been passing through bits where
they're just filaments of small debris,
but the evidence is that it is actually
full of large lucky rocky debris,
including one object that maybe as much
as 30 kilometers in diameter sitting in
that tour in meteor stream.
So it's like I compare
it to like strapping on a
blindfold and crossing a six
lane highway and just hoping that you
don't get hit by a truck. You know,
that's what it, that's what it
comes down to. And we've been,
we've been lucky so far.
Actually,
the most recent definite impact
from the Taurid meteor stream, uh,
was in 1,908 and that
was in Russia in Siberia.
It's called the Tom Gasca event.
As I said,
there's two passages through the stream.
One in June,
end of June or early
July and one in November.
And this was at the end of June
and object, not very big. Uh,
about a hundred meters in diameter.
Came out of the Taurid meteor stream,
entered the atmosphere of the earth
and actually blew up in the sky.
It was an air burst about five kilometers
where the ground it flattened 80
million trees across
2000 square kilometers.
I'm sorry I keep using kilometers was
2000 square kilometers of the earth's
surface. That's an area about
the size of the city of London.
If that impact had happened
over an inhabited area,
hundreds of thousands of people would be
killed and we would all be paying much
more attention to the Taurid meteor
stream today than we are presently doing.
We should be paying attention to it.
So we just got super lucky that it hit
in a very lightly populated area and it
didn't even hit and blew up
in the sky above it. Pull up,
see if you can find some image of Tom
Guskey cause it's pretty staggering and it
literally looks like there was like a
match stick forest and someone pushed over
like a series of dominoes or something.
Yeah, yeah. Oh God. Jamie, Jamie,
Jamie is a wizard kids out
in the ball over there. Yeah.
So,
so here's the thing,
we are still interacting with the debris
of this comment that changed the world.
12,800 years ago. It, it, it's
not something remote and distant.
It's part of our,
it's part of our daily lives and,
and it is something we should be paying
attention to and a number of astronomers
are very concerned about
the tour it meteor stream.
Now I don't want to be the
one who goes around the world,
you know where in the Sandwich board
saying that doom is nigh, sky is falling.
Yeah. I don't want to be that.
I don't want to manifest that.
I don't want to bring that down.
I actually want to say that there's
something positive to say about this.
We are almost certainly the first
civilization that's ever existed on this
planet that has the capacity to
intervene in our cosmic environment.
Should we choose to do so.
We can make sure that we are
not the next loss civilization.
We can make sure that life and light
continue on this planet and that our story
continues, but we need to pay
attention to our cosmic environment.
And a number of scientists are
now saying the same thing, that,
that it's irresponsible of us to pretend
that impacts like this may they just
happen every hundred million years.
We don't need to worry about them.
We are intimately connected with a force
that can change life on earth and we
have the power to do something about it.
So I would suggest instead of wasting,
you know, trillions of
dollars globally, uh,
creating weapons of mass destruction
to destroy one another and to,
to manifest the hatred and
fear and suspicion that had
just whizzing around the
world. Right now we should be
looking at a grand human project,
a cooperative effort to make
our cosmic environment safe.
And we have the technology now.
It's just a matter of choice.
It's just a matter of budget.
Trillions of dollars are spent on arms
and roughly 20 to $30 million are spent a
year on so-called space watch.
It's a ridiculous of chump change
given the nature of the threat and the
implications
about the same as the cost to run one
Mcdonald's restaurant for a year is what
we're spending on studying the cosmic
environment in terms of threats.
That's a hilarious comparison.
Yeah.
What a resourceful little
freaky animal people are.
If you really stop and think about it
almost wiped off the face of the planet,
you know,
ten thousand twelve thousand years ago.
And then we reach a point where here
we are in 2015 and through all these
inventions were starting to rediscover
what our history truly is and rediscover
the, the history of
the earth and, and its,
its interplay with all these
cosmic forces, you know,
modern humans but have now 199,000
yeah.
The earliest,
I mean the earliest definite anatomically
modern human skeletal remains date
back about 196,000 years.
There's some other plausible ones at
about 210,000 years. Nothing before that.
It doesn't mean that we were not
anatomically modern before that.
It may just mean that archaeologists
haven't found that the data yet,
but we can be sure that people like
you and me have been around for about
200,000 years with the anatomically
modern form and the anatomically modern
brain.
So there's a mystery right there.
Why did we wait 190,000 years to
establish the first civilizations?
It,
it raises the possibility that we could
have done so much earlier and that the
slate has been wiped clean.
Think about it this way,
Joe.
My grandfather was born in 1895 the
main mode of transportation aside from
railroads at that time, was horseback,
right? His grandfather, you know,
would've been born pre civil war.
So when five generations,
we've gone from the very first railroads,
the beginning of the industrial
revolution to where we are now in five
generations. Now, if you
go back 200,000 years,
say 196,000 and we divide that by 25 I
love and random breaks out there looking
at it almost,
we're looking at almost 8,000
generations of humans. Wow. Yeah.
Now think about that. Within
five generations. We've gone from
90% dominant agriculturally
based subsistence farming,
right feudal system to where we are now.
But now we've got 8,000 generations of
humans on this planet who knows what we
may have accomplished in the past.
But once you put this perspective and,
and you got to understand that the,
that the catastrophe,
we're talking about 12,000 years ago,
while all the evidence suggests
it was the most severe,
probably at least within 5 million years
because the last time we can find a
species loss equivalent to the terminal
pleistocene species loss was 5 million
years ago. The hamp helion
event it's called, um,
which then I would then
consider that again is a,
is a measuring stick for habitat loss,
which would in turn be a measure of
the severity of whatever happened.
But the point is, is that in the
time that we humans have been around,
there have been multiple
catastrophes of a global scale.
Not as severe as the one we're
talking about here, but certainly the,
the framework of this planet
has been shaken numerous times.
And in 200,000 years,
we've had probably four great glacial
cycles that have come and gone. Now,
just a glacial cycle alone.
I mean, think about that,
what the ice will do to the landscape and,
and dropping sea levels 400
feet and now during an ice age,
you've got to bear in mind that probably
the most habitable place to be on the
plan that is going to be on coastlines
along the miles of rivers and so forth.
What happens when all that ice melts
and sea level comes up three or 400 feet
and,
and it's going to pretty much a race,
most of the evidence of human habitation.
Although,
and I think I talked about this last
time and you would probably concur with
this, the importance of marine
archeology. It's extremely important. Yes.
But again, unfortunately, marine
archeology has its eye off the ball.
Most of the resources in Marina killogy
going to shipwrecks looking for looking
for shipwrecks. Right.
Um, and, and you know,
I get that it's a really interesting
to look at shipwrecks, but,
but there is a prejudice in archeology
which says that could have been no
interesting civilization before
12,000 years ago. So since the,
those lands that were submerged by rising
sea levels had been underwater for 10
to 12,000 years, we're not
really interested in human
habitations there. And, and,
and this is the problem,
a very focused effort needs to be
made to look at these lost lands.
I can put that in miles, 10 million
square miles of the earth's surface,
roughly Europe and China added together
was submerged by the rising sea levels
at the end of the last ice age.
That's what's missing from the record.
You know, and, and again,
we're talking about wiping the
slate clean and rattles right.
Those ice caps that sit on top of a
continent, which are mountain high,
they're going to just
ground grind to powder,
anything that lies below them.
So was there a civilization there before
where the ice cap formed?
Who knows,
right. Yeah. A mile high of ice. Yeah.
Even more in some cases
over over central Canada,
it might've been as much as two miles,
two miles,
just pushing across the ground like an
eraser. Exactly. Writing everything,
crushing the surface of the ground down.
I think in our discussions of Atlantis,
we covered that a little bit.
Crushing the surface of the, uh,
of the land down by perhaps a couple
of thousand feet. Isostatic depression.
You remember the geology lesson I
gave you last time about icer static
depression and we discussed how at
this very moment the your ass is
demonstrating an important
geological phenomena of Isis,
static depression sitting on net cushion
cause you're sitting on and if you were
to stand up, what happens when you stand
up? The cushion comes back up, doesn't it?
It's exactly what happens.
And you can almost picture the planet
breathing and affect the, the, the,
the ice is released from
the continental surface.
The continental surface begins to rebound.
The weight is transferred back into the
ocean basins and there has to be that
what's called Realogy,
which is the study of the distribution
of the inner mass of the earth requires
that there be compensation.
So if if in one area of the surface
the land is rising somewhere else,
it has to be subsiding.
And the obvious place would be that
as you transfer the weight from the
continent back into the ocean basins, that
the ocean basins are going to subside.
And this brings us to the
whole question of, of, of uh,
of the scientific veracity of,
of a sunken landmass.
You're thinking, you have an interesting
point on the age of yours in this,
in this sense,
because then you have this massive,
it's like a see saw that you have this
massive weight pressing down on the North
American continent and suddenly
it's lifted that, that,
that massive weight pushed down North
America, but it lifted up other areas.
The other end of the seesaw
and the weight comes off,
this end goes up and the other end
goes down and suddenly you get the
possibility of the submergence of a
land mass. It just falls under the sea.
And there is actually
considerable empirical evidence
suggesting that there was
massive post glacial subsidence
along the Mid Atlantic Ridge,
which is where the are. Yeah. Yeah.
And which is pretty much were
Plato said Atlanta's work. Yeah.
Wasn't there some discovery of some
concentric circles that were submerged
somewhere near Spain that they
considered to be a possible
Cadiz? Um, I don't think that
near Spain. Yeah, it's, it's um,
I think it's much more recent. Okay.
Much, much more recent than the,
than the information we're looking
at another, yeah, that was submerged.
That was so much, that can be a lot of
reasons why this, why, why this happens.
Actually it's happening in the,
in the UK where I'm from because the ice
sheets in the UK where on the north of
the UK,
over Scotland and they were pressing
Scotland down and they closed the southern
part of England to rise up.
Then when you take those ice sheets off,
the southern part starts go down.
So that's places like the isle
of wight in the English Channel,
they're sinking beneath
the sea because of this.
Still the effect of that
rebound is happening to them.
Glacial four bulge
outside the, the glaciers.
The land is pushed up.
You know,
this speaks to how people have a
hard time accepting some of this new
information. I have a friend
who's a scientist and a,
the last time you were on,
she said to me, did you have
a climate denier on your show?
A climate change denier? And I say that
he's definitely not denying it. No,
but some people, that's all they
hear. When you bring forth, uh,
a non mainstream point of view
or a controversial perspective,
instead of considering the possibility,
it almost immediately gets dismissed.
This climate change thing is another
ideological struggle. Yeah, sure.
Climate change is taking place, but
what are the causes for this? You know,
are we so sure that it's
all caused by human beings?
I would say there's very good reason for
humanity to clean up our act in lots of
ways. Regardless of the issue of
climate change we're living, we're,
we're abusing mother earth. We are
living upon this planet, uh, like,
like parasites and,
and destroying it.
We thoughtlessly create
this gigantic pools of,
of pollution where we're crazy enough,
insane enough to actually invent
nuclear weapons and you know,
long periods of detonate that like
of things, you know, this is the,
the lots about our behavior that we
need to fix because it's right to fix it
philosophically, right? We
should not behave that way.
We should not behave
that way to one another.
that way to planet earth.
But to say that we need to fix our
behavior because of global warming,
that's an ideological argument. And that
argument remains to be properly tested.
Yes, global warming is occurring, but are
we the cause of it or is something else,
some, some grander scale
cosmic effect involved in this?
We talked about that considerably. And
I noticed in a lot of the comments from,
from our last discussion, most of
the critical comments where people,
you know,
not liking the idea that I had
questioned the dogma of global warming,
but there are some facts
that you can't escape. No.
The global warming again 200 years ago,
and we see that the glaciers from the
little ice age began to shrink back.
And your early 19th century
before there was, you know,
a century before there was any significant
human contract contribution of co two
to the atmosphere. So something was
driving that warming that began.
And it's important to realize that the
little ice age was probably the coldest
period since the end of the great ice age.
In fact,
the data overwhelmingly supports that
end that the glaciers grew to their
largest extent around the
planet and 10,000 years.
So when we're talking
about glacier recession,
it's important to understand
what the baseline is.
Our baseline in this case is the biggest,
the glaciers have been in 10,000 years.
And what's interesting,
and this is going on right now,
as the glaciers had been receding,
geologists and biologists
and and glaciologists and
so forth have been studying,
um, the landscapes that are being revealed
as the ice shrinks back. And you know,
what they're finding is the remains of
forests that had been overrun by the
Little Ice Age glaciers
up, you know, and, and,
and peat bogs and things that would
suggest that prior to the onset of the
little ice age,
those valleys that were filled
with ice from roughly 1400 to 1800,
we're actually forested because the ice
came down and overran these forests and
now it's receding back and revealing
that there were forests there.
So that tells you that,
you know, at some point,
probably going back to the medieval
warm period, those areas that were,
that have been glaciated during the early
part of the 20th century were actually
free of ice. And so, you know, the
climate has been extremely dynamic.
That's the thing we have to emphasize all
by itself without any help from humans.
And this is what I've been saying is that
we have to look at that and realize it.
Yeah, humans are a factor. You know,
somebody I did post and said all the
other factors I had mentioned as you know,
ocean currents and wind currents and
geomagnetic field and cosmic rays and
volcanism and all that.
It all been investigated in dismissed.
And the only thing left was the
human contribution. But you know,
to me that's really,
we're putting all our eggs in that
basket and that could turn out to be very
dangerous because we're so focused now
on our own contribution that we might be
overlooking the fact that there have been
natural factors driving climate change
over and over and over again.
I mean,
because I still have not heard any
consensus on what has caused the planet to
first go into an ice age and
come back out of an ice age.
And I think that would bring him and I
are talking about actually presents a
possible solution to what could have
brought this planet out of the Ice Age.
Something on a grand cosmic scale.
And the other point I think I'd like
to make is that we have to really to
understand our planet as a system,
we have to realize that it's part of a
cosmic ecosystem and the cosmos has been
a much bigger player in what's been
going on down here than has been a
previously understood or appreciated.
And I think our ancestors probably did
Tuesday, they did understand it.
They, the focus on the skies,
if you go back into ancient times, is
so strong. This notion of as above.
So below that we are connected
to the cosmos. This is,
this is something that we are tending
to forget in the modern world again
because we're so puffed up with pride
anywhere we can't see the sky if they live
in sending a big issue. Collusion, it's
just like a haze up there. We don't,
we don't, we don't, we
don't see anything. So we,
we're actually cut off from the cosmos
it psychologically. And that's a,
that's a mistake because we are part
of this giant cosmic environment and it
affects us.
And one of the way it affects us is the
way that comments come into the inner
solar system from to time,
from deep space.
I was camping in Montana recently and uh,
you know when you're out at night and
you look at that night sky and there's no
light pollution.
Yeah,
it's just a totally different perspective
and it gives you a different sense of
where you are in the universe
because we're so, and it's not a,
it's not necessarily our fault.
It's almost like we've put up a curtain
over the heavens and we can't see
through the curtain because we've decided
that we like light and we like traffic
lights and you know,
building lights and all this jazz.
And we don't realize until we're out in
the woods or in the wild until you were
in the wilderness and
there's no light pollution,
you really don't realize
what we're missing and what
we're sacrificing in order
to have these lights. The
view of the heavens. It's,
it's so it's psychedelic in a way you
back cause it makes you feel like,
oh my God, we're really
flying through space and nice.
That by the nature has provided us
with those plots that really help us to
appreciate it from him.
I tried to go every year to the
Keck observatory on the big island.
I tried to schedule my a holidays as
much as possible around the time where
there's no moon because it is unbelievable
because the Keck observatory is more
than 9,000 feet above sea.
If there's a visitor center and then
there's the observatories above,
but you really don't even know have to
go past the visitor center. But they're,
the way they have it set up,
they have these special streetlights all
throughout the pig island with diffused
lighting.
So it doesn't interfere.
It doesn't give you light pollution and
when you're up there, you're, you're,
you go through the clouds
and the view is insane.
If it doesn't look real, it doesn't even
look real. Like you see all the stars,
you're like, this can't be real.
How could this be up there?
Every day and we don't see it.
But what we've done is create
all this incredible stuff,
these streets and buildings and
laptops and cell phones and in the,
in doing so we have robbed
ourselves. Have a perspective. Yeah.
It's weird because you know,
we,
we have this technology that enables
us to go around the whole world and,
and even go out into outer
space. But actually we, in a way,
it's narrowed our focus. We, we, we've,
we focus in on the all the technology
and its products and we forget about the
majestic cosmic and earth environment
in which we, in which we live,
how sacred it is, how beautiful it
is, how meaningful it is to all of us.
And that was the image that
our ancestors always had.
That's probably why they
concentrated on it so much.
And the things that happened up
there were evident to them. I mean,
because these days,
how many people see meteors
living in an urban environment?
You never see that hardly unless it's
really spectacular. But you go out,
like you said in Montana or the one of
my favorite places to garden into high
desert country and there you really,
it's well the stars or how much you
can reach out and touch him. You know,
I think that one of the most important
things that we could do for future
generations is part of our educational
curriculum for young people
is get them out of the cds into nature,
into the tremendous, you know,
where they can actually see the sky.
Because I mean, I'm living in
Atlanta, I'll talk to people,
even grown up people that have have
no clue. I have no clue. You know,
you couldn't,
they couldn't find the north star,
they couldn't find the plane
of the ecliptic if their
life depended on it. They,
you know, they're just, we've, we've
become cut off from that level.
And I think that that's,
it's important for us to keep that because
our consciousness is linked to this
greater domain and, and we have
segregated ourselves from that. And,
and I think that there's something
there, you know, amazingly, it's a,
it's a grounding experience.
When you get out in you,
you begin to see the sky and
you can actually, um, you know,
begin to figure out in, in
identify the constellations. Um,
you know, to, to know where the planets
are to, to look in the sky in, in
good mental exercise.
It's something with anybody doing get
to grips with all that up there as the
ancients did,
it gets your mind working.
And it may even have been
used deliberately for that
purpose in ancient times.
People kind of initiation system. If you
can get this, then you move on to the,
to the next level. You know, that's the,
that's the, that's the kind of idea.
It was a critical part of education where
it's very rarely even discussed today.
And look again at the ideology.
So for example,
if you talk about astrology to any most,
any mainstream scientists,
they're going to laugh in your face.
And you've got to say pseudoscience
because they're so locked into this earth
centered perspective that which,
which convinces them that the
cosmos does have no effect on us.
So how can changing patterns of the
stars that that which is a dye called
constellation is sitting behind
the sign at a particular time.
How can that effect us?
How can when we were born effect us?
I don't think we should throw that
baby out with the bath water too fast.
I think we're looking at an
ancient science with, uh,
with astrology and I think it's worth it.
It's been heavily diluted and
prostituted in the modern world debate.
But if you go back to the antiquity,
you go back to the real origins of
this and you start finding some very
interesting information coming out.
There's a fantastic book by a guy called
Rick Tarnas called Cosmos and psyche
and he's a real mainstream,
a very major academic.
And he's got into this and
he's shown that actually, yeah,
astrology does have effects.
So we should not,
we should not deny our cosmic environment.
That's the first thing we
need to do to connect to it.
And we shouldn't close ourselves off
to avenues of inquiry for ideological
reasons.
It's,
it's noticeable in this field of ancient
history how archeologists throw around
words like pseudo archeologist
or pseudo scientists.
That's meant to be an instant
dismissal just like climate deniers,
climate denier. You call somebody a
climate denier today. That's like saying,
don't listen to anything that guy has
to say, never listened to it. Again,
these are ideological tools which are
being used to straight jacket the human
mind and to stop us thinking outside the
box and if there's ever a time where we
needed think outside the box.
I would say that time is right now.
Isn't it ironic that in this time of
more information available to the average
person than ever before,
that this also has coincided with our
lack of appreciation for what's above us.
It's very strange that it's
a very curious phenomenon.
Here's an interesting perspective.
You know,
as we're talking about how dynamic the
plan it is and how it's changed and how
dramatically different which it is.
I mean,
if we go back to the end of the ice
age, you know, you go east of here,
a lot of the Mojave desert that
was lush grasslands and forests,
you out here to the Santa Rosa Islands,
you know,
out here they were all forested with
oak trees and beech trees and, and uh,
mammoth mammoth, this Exilis, which was
the pygmy mammoth. You know, I mean,
everything down here changes dramatically.
But when we go out and we look at the sky,
we're basically seeing the same sky
that our ancestors have 20,000 years ago
were looking at. And that's something to
keep in mind because there is something,
there's a backdrop to all of
this drama and change here below.
That's pretty much for the most part,
remained consistent.
But within that backdrop of consistency,
every once in a while something shifts.
And when it shifts out there,
I think our ancestors knew that there
was a direct consequence here below.
And that's one of the reasons
they were so obsessed with,
with being able to track
motion. Um, you know,
all of these ancient observatories
from Stonehenge on down the line to,
you know, the, the, the mountain
structures here in North America.
Let's not forget it. Go back to the
Tempe. Profoundly astronomical science.
Real Beckley Tepi yes,
these were astronomical observatories
using the horizon essentially as a
telescope by which very
intimate and intricate movements
within that backdrop of
fixed stars could actually be observed
possibly for predictive capabilities.
And how are the calculations may like
an archeologist finds a site like go
Beverly, go, go Beckley.
Tappy how do they correlate
the construction of the
site with the Constellation?
Fist off, mo, most archaeologists don't,
don't do that at all because they just
don't do astronomy. They don't get it.
They have their eyes are on the ground
at their feet to the disciplines because
astronomy is not relevant to them.
They project that onto the past and
imagined that it was not relevant to the
past. And that's one of the big
mistakes I think that it makes.
There are people call dot Kao Astronomy's,
uh,
who are looking at the
astronomy of ancient cultures.
And some of them have done very good work.
But really there,
there are certain key indicators,
um, eh, the alignment of the site,
what's it pointing at and does that
alignment change down the ages? Um,
you can sometimes establish that a,
that a particular access of a particular
template in Egypt for example,
was shifted over a period of two or
3000 years, several times. And why?
Because they were tracking the changing
rising point of the star Sirius,
which they connected in their
system of ideas to the goddess Isis.
They were tracking that
point which changes
because of changes in in the sky.
I mean the long story short,
the earth wobbles on its axis and that
since the earth is our viewing platform
from which we observe the stars,
changes of orientation of
the earth in space do change.
The rising times of particular stars
at particular times of year and, and a,
this was clearly tracked by the ancient.
So you can say that if you find anywhere
a monument that is perfectly aligned to
true north, south, east, and West,
you can be absolutely sure
that astronomers were involved.
If it's tracking the rising sun on the
spring equinox or on the winter or summer
solstice, astronomers were there.
They were right there when they met,
they made that monument.
Well,
that's one of the scariest that we're
not the scariest but most astounding
things when you consider the ancients
that they had an understanding of the
procession of the equinoxes,
which is what it was a 26,000 years.
So 26,000 year cycle,
25,920 years.
How the very long,
very precise observations and the motive
to make those observations that this
was important to them and they sought
to pass down that importance to us.
Um, very important work by two historians
of science called Giorgio decentered,
Yana and Hertha von Deshint back in the
60s they wrote a book called Hamlet's
mill, which tracks this ancient knowledge
of precession and they trace it back.
And this was very politically uncorrect
at that time because George has said,
Alana, so the Santee Deanna
was the professor of the
history of science at Mit.
They trace it back to what they call
some almost unbelievable civilization of
pre historic antiquity
that made the subsidy.
They found the data encoded in myths
and traditions all around the world.
And I do go into this in
magicians of the gods. They,
they found it encoded as though the
data was so important that it had to be
passed down to the future.
So the numbers that relate to
precession of the equinoxes,
and they're all based on the number
72 and multiples of that number. Why?
Because it takes 72 years for one
degree of processional change to unfold.
And that's like holding your
finger up to the horizon.
That one degree is just that one
finger width of change on the horizon.
Very precise observations
and needed to do it.
It's encoded and miss and traditions.
And it looks like somebody at some
point decided this information is so
important, we must make sure that it
stays permanently in human culture.
So what we're gonna do is we're
going to encode it in great stories,
and those stories can then be passed on
by storytellers who will have an ethic
that they must tell the story.
True.
It doesn't matter whether they understand
the scientific information in the
story or not.
All that matters is that they pass it on.
And so in the oldest myths
and traditions of mankind,
we have compelling evidence for scientific
knowledge of the phenomenon that we
call the precession of the
equinoxes today, which has
been referred to by, by, um,
in Hamlet's mill is the great year,
a great year,
which is the full cycle,
25,000,
920 years a great circle in the heavens.
It's very evident if you've got
thousands of years to watch.
The Sky is very evident at the pole.
Um,
our Pollstar presently is Polaris,
and that's just simply
because the extended North
Pole of the earth points most
directly at that particular
star in the sky. Uh,
but it hasn't always pointed at Polaris
because of the wobble on the axis of the
earth. And it won't always
point at Polaris in the
future, the Pollstar changes,
but you need to observe the skies
for very long periods of time.
Keep detailed records to get
to grips with this phenomenon.
This debt therefore testifies to the
fact that some ancient culture was doing
this in a very systematic way.
It's like a ghostly fingerprint of an
advanced scientific knowledge impressed
upon the oldest myths and traditions of
our planet. Has it been six? I'm sorry.
Is it it, has it been accepted that
things like the Mayan temples were,
were built to mirror the constellations
cause that except it has been accepted?
Yeah,
it is.
It is accepted because we know that the
Maya where we're an astronomical culture
and it is, it is accepted that
they were building their, their,
their temples in connection to the sky
and the whole phenomenon of the Mayan
calendar. Um, w which we all
heard a lot about in, in,
in 2012, uh, is, is another
factor to take into account.
The Mayan calendar, in my view, is
another artifact of a lost civilization.
This is the,
that was handed down from a former people
perhaps to the all macs and then to
the the, the Maya who who succeeded
them. It's, it's accepted,
but the implications of it are not,
are not taken properly into account
remembered 21st of December,
2012 there was all that fast and nonsense
about the end of the world happening,
happening then and, and it didn't.
But that's my, I never said that.
They said that the end of a
great cycle happened then,
which would ultimately
transform the world, but what
it was actually locked into,
and I need to pay tribute to another
researcher here and his name is John Major
Jenkins.
John Major Jenkins has done fantastic
work on the Mayan calendar and decade
before 2012 he was telling people,
look,
this is not talking about the end of the
world on a specific day on the 21st of
December, 2012 there's a, there's
a calculation behind this.
And what he showed in that calculation
is that it is the position of the winter
solstice sun against the
background of the constellations.
And what has been happening for the last
5,000 years because of procession is
that the Winter Solstice,
Sun 21st of December,
against the background of
the constellations has been
gradually shifting towards
alignment with the center of the
galaxy. And that alignment happened, uh,
on the 21st of December,
2012 but it's not an instant,
it's a window and that window
is about 80 years wide,
roughly from 1960 to 2040.
That was what was focused
on in the Mayan calendar.
A calendar that can predict eclipses of
the moon 200,000 years into the future,
or 200,000 years into the past.
Incredible,
stunning accuracy.
A better estimate of the length of the
solar year than we use today in our
modern calculations. Really? Yeah. Wow.
High Science and coated in that,
in that calendar.
Why don't we just adopt the Mayan
calendar if it's better than what we have?
I don't, yeah. We now living in
the fifth stage of the world,
according to the Mayan, the Mayan
use may not have been. Yeah,
it's probably not good for your iPhone.
It wouldn't make a good app. I've got,
they have a mine, I have mine calendar.
I'm sure they do. You can think of one,
one, one half of a degree. Graham
said one degree every 72 years,
right? One degree within degree ear
is like one day out of the great year.
Right? So you could think of 72 years
as basically being a human life.
So an average human life is roughly
like a day of the great year.
That's one way. One perspective.
Interesting. Yeah. Yeah. No,
what he said about the window is,
because you can't define
the center of the galaxy,
would that an exact precise point?
There's a diffuse area there
and every 72 years, the,
the, this, the spring
point is moving one degree,
which is twice the
diameter of a full moon.
Full Moon is a half a degree. Right. Okay.
And I think that possibly one of
the importances of monitoring, um,
because you can't really, you
know, you can't go out and
look at the sun, you know,
and say, okay, here's The sun relative
to this backdrop of this constellation.
However, you can look at, uh,
a full lunar eclipse and then you,
you will know that the
sun is 180 degrees around.
So by monitoring lunar eclipses,
you can actually position the sun quite
precisely and know where it is in the
sky because obviously you can't go out
and look at the sun and see what stars
it's, it's related to, right,
right. But during a lunar eclipse,
lunar eclipse,
it's 180 degrees almost precisely on
the other side of the earth from the,
from the sun.
So can,
can I just jump in for a second
because I have an image here.
I don't know if we can get it on the tap.
And it's this image on, on this side,
it's a pillow with originally
carved a shelling. Uh,
is that pillar 1443 43 and enclosure day?
Not I'm,
I'm not going to go into it in
detail and I've seen that online,
but Jamie will find images online.
I just want to,
I just want to make the point
and I go into this in this book,
magicians of the Gods that,
that that appears to be a diagram of
the sky at the winter solstice in our
epoch. This, this red, the round
dots above the vultures wing,
the round circle represents the sun.
And what we're looking at is an
ancient constellation diagram.
The constellations that we call
Sagittarius in school, Po, uh,
stand on side
of the galactic center of the, of the
dark rift at the heart of the Milky Way,
which the Maya saw is the
womb of cosmic rebirth.
And it's precisely that
image that is depicted there.
Back it up chapter and verse in the book.
You'll just have to take,
so what we see the Scorpion
below. Yeah, there's a,
there's an ancient memory that there
should be a scorpion in that area of the
sky.
And it's impressed here
on this, on this, on this pillar. And
what are the other constellation clues?
Well, the, the, up on the
right, you'll see first of all,
see the vulture with its wings
outstretched and his son over the wing.
Then go right up there,
you'll see a bird.
That's that small bird is actually the
head of our constellation of Scorpio.
The tail of our constellation of Scorpio
overlaps the Scorpion a underneath the
pillar, but go above the small bird
and you'll see a serpent there,
a snake, and beside it, another
bird that looks like a penis. Villi.
Those represent,
we call those,
we call those constellations today
or futures, the serpent holder,
which is the represented
by the bird there.
And we call the serpent constellation.
So pants are there,
other constellations are,
are, are also involved. It,
this is spooky and eerie because it
appears there's overwhelming evidence that
the people who made go Beckley Tapi had
a profound knowledge of procession and
it appears that they deliberately sent
forward into time in this time capsule,
a picture of the sky in our age.
And that is a staggering possibility that,
uh,
that I investigators 10
how it's in our age. Well,
it's only at the winter solstice in our
age that the sun sits over the center of
the galaxy,
the winter solstice in the area that
the ancient Maya called the cosmic womb.
There's a dark rift in the
Milky Way at that point.
And they saw that as the cosmic womb.
So it symbolizes a moment of rebirth.
And the evidence is that they'd been
tracking the movement of the sun on the
winter solstice,
which is also the end of the year.
And the rebirth of the new year.
They'd been tracking it to the point
where they could project forward and they
could envisage the sky in our epoch today.
The Meijer could do that.
And what I'm suggesting is that's
done correctly Tapi as well.
Well, it's very hard for
me to interpret those. Uh,
I'm seeing the vulture playing basketball
and trying to get away from the
Scorpion and there's a
penis trying to attack them.
And I'm not exactly sure that the
photograph alone, that's just the best.
Just the heart of the mystery.
You have to get into the logic of
it and compare it with the existing
constellations.
And I've tried to do that.
Well it's also fascinating that all
of these images were carved in three d
relief.
So instead of being what would that
means is instead of being drawn like into
like you know,
people think about like wet cement,
you can draw your name in wet cement
instead of that what they've done is
they've removed everything
around it to create these images,
which is a much more sophisticated
is right. This is what's
called high high relief.
Um,
interestingly you can see at the top of
the pillar there are three that look,
things that looked like handbags,
that symbol crops up all over the world.
It crops up in Mexico, it crops up
in Mesopotamia, crops up in India,
everywhere.
And again,
I think we're looking at at symbolism
that goes back to a very remote period,
which we know is at least as old as 11th.
And maybe what they're trying to say is
that shopping will be the end of a saw.
I think those bags held desk stash really,
and I'm half serious because this is,
this is another issue that that is
ignored by the mainstream is the use of
psychedelics in ancient civilizations
was fundamental to the quality of those
civilizations. And this is another
area where in ideological denial about,
because the powers that be in our
society don't like psychedelics.
They don't want ancient cultures to have
liked the my there and they just ignore
the evidence for that.
I think it's one of the
main points of view that uh,
when you don't consider them,
it makes me really reluctant to listen
to a lot of the other things you have to
say because it's,
it's undeniable the impact those
things have on human consciousness.
And it's also undeniable that many,
many,
many civilizations used them as a
part of their spiritual rituals.
And the fact that this is not thought of
as an important aspect of our history.
When it all it means to me is the people
that are talking about and have an
experience. Exactly.
That's the policy only.
Yeah. Who are the, the,
the entrusted with
interpreting our past to us.
Unfortunately, most of them had never
taken a psychedelic in their life,
so they don't know what they mean.
No,
look,
I just need 15 minutes of your time and
one DM teaching 15 minutes and the whole
thing will be so much clearer.
How much
clearer exactly.
It's,
I think it's an important experience for
archeologists to have because it was a
universal experience in the ancient world.
We demonize psychedelics today and we,
we pretend that they are just totally
negative things, but in the ancient world,
they were revered and enshrined. They were
at the heart of the ancient mysteries.
The Eleusinian mysteries in ancient
Greece used a potion related to Lsd,
which brought about a
revelation for the initiates,
changed their lives just in the way that
a powerful psychedelic trip can change
our lives today.
So just like writing about history and
the origins of civilization without
taking account of, whoops, this gigantic
cataclysm that happened 12,800 years ago,
that's a mistake that
archaeology is making.
The other mistake they're
making is they're not
considering the role of altered
states of consciousness
in ancient civilizations.
Ideological Blinders ideologic keep
us from looking at possibilities.
I don't know whether or not that stash
or that's just chicks handbag sang
shopping malls, malls were ruined us
all. That's the way. The thing is,
the weird thing is that it's all that,
that this symbolism is all over the world.
What have got back Lee tabby was a mall.
The,
that's how you may have something back.
This symbolism of these purses. Yeah.
Yeah. It's found on the web. For example.
Um, we'd have to find a,
an, an image, but there's a,
the earliest image of the figure known
as quite sal collateral in Mexico,
uh, survives from, uh,
the old Mech area of the Gulf of Mexico.
And it was founded a site
called love Venta, uh,
along with a lot of other
buried stone artifacts.
And it shows a man sitting within the
coils of a serpent and that serpent has a
crest on its head because
that's what quotes are.
Collateral means it means
a feathered serpent.
And that man is holding one of those bags
just the same as the Sumerian Fishman.
Oh,
Anis.
The one adapta the the originator
of civilization in Suma,
ancient, ancient Sumeria.
According to their mythology,
he's always depicted holding
one of these bags as well.
So I find myself wondering,
are we looking at the symbolism of
some ancient brotherhood, you know,
who passed around the world seeding
civilizations and that this was the
equivalent of their, I dunno, their
masonic handshake or something.
This was their badge of recognition,
this bag that they carried them. Well,
it's just speculation, right?
It's, it's fewer speculators thing.
It's pure speculation, but so
because of the fact that we, the,
they've accepted that the mind temples
are aligned with the constellations.
Have they decided to look
at other archeological
discoveries in the same light
or is it something are,
there is a specialized
subdivision of archeology,
which is called archeo astronomers
except this subdivision. These are,
these are archeologists who
have been trained in astronomy,
but they've also been trained in the
fundamental dogmas of the discipline of
archeology, which is that there
can be no lost civilization.
That archeology has already told pretty
much the full story of humanity and
they're all the weights. All the weights
is to fill in the details. This is,
this is the dogma of archeology that is
taken in from the moment that somebody
decides to become an archeologist.
Part of the training,
and actually if you try and go against
that dogma as a mainstream archeologist,
you can kiss goodbye to your career.
Any archeologist who
entertains the possibility of
an advance lost civilization
around the world more than 12,000
years ago will have no future as an
archeologist. That right there, we'll
write him off for the rest of his career.
That's so disturbing. Disturbing.
If that's true. That's so,
it's so mind numbing cause why would
you ever believe that we've got it all
figured out where every day
they find some new stuff.
Did you see the discovery they found
recently of a large tooth that's a cousin
of a,
of human beings then serve and re,
but really recently within the
last few days, very recently. Well,
this is the thing you see the our,
our story is much more complex that we've
been taught and gradually by bit the
evidence is coming out of the woodwork.
Well,
the idea that we have all the
data of history is just so crazy.
It's just our true and arrogant.
It's absolutely foolish.
It's a very foolish idea and it,
and it shuts us down to the,
to the possibilities.
I mean the universe gifted us with
these giant brains and this incredible
imagination and intuitive
faculties as well.
We not only rational creatures where
we're intuitive creatures and all of these
faculties should be applied
to understanding the mystery
of who and what we are.
And I think that's one of the mistakes
of modern science is there's just chopped
out one bit that kind of alert
problem solving, the rational reason,
the use of reason and logic and it, and
it's chopped out all the rest. The, the,
the, the, the capacity
of humanity to dream,
to learn information and dream to learn,
learn true knowledge in dream was
revered in the ancient world and just
ridiculed today. You want
to insult somebody called
him a dreamer, you know, uh,
things of things have changed so much.
Well it seems like back then there
was so much less information.
Now there's so much information to call
someone. A dreamer means that you're,
you're thinking of nonsense when you
should be trying to acquire all the
information that we've already discovered
that we've already cumulated. Exactly.
That's exactly what it's about.
And again, it's, it's ideology.
It's saying that there is
nothing of value and dreams.
How do we know that ancient world felt
that there was useful knowledge to be got
from, from dreams, not all
dreams. It's in homer actually,
the speaks of the gate of
ivory and the gate of Horn.
Some dreams come through
the gate of ivory.
They're just pleasant fictions or maybe
unpleasant ones. Nightmares, ignore them.
They're not important.
But others are true.
Tellings and they come through
the gate of Horn. Uh, and,
and this was a recognized factor in the
ancient world. We've dismissed it today.
It's regarded as pseudoscience.
It's regarded as nonsense. Again,
that label is constantly applied to
anything. Archaeologists don't alike.
Pseudoscience. D right there with a
label. They just dismiss everything.
They always call me a pseudo scientists,
which means a false scientist.
And I find that bizarre because
I'm not a scientist at all.
I've never claimed to be a scientist.
I don't want to be a scientist.
I'm a writer. I'm a journalist. I,
I synthesize material across
a broad range of disciplines.
So how can I be a false scientist
since I've never claimed to be one.
But the word is used as a bludgeon or a
club to beat an enemy over the head and
ensured that nobody listens to what
that enemy centers sort of a bulletproof
pejorative. You know, you throw that out
there and you're immediately dismissed.
Yeah. But it's got to be satisfying
to you going from that original book,
which I became absolutely fascinated by
fingerprints of the gods to or slowly
but surely over time,
more and more evidence being
discovered in mainstream science,
in archeology that affirms all
these suspicions. And then,
uh, attached to what Randall has been
studying his whole life. It really,
the whole thing just sort of unfolds
in front of your eyes. There's a,
there's a kind of perfect perfect moment
in human knowledge unfolding right now.
We now have the knowledge of this giant
cataclysm that happened 12,800 years
ago,
which has just not been taken into account
at all up to now and at the same time
and it's almost eerie.
Archaeological sites are popping up
all around the world that cannot be
explained by the previous
model of history.
Now with all of this information that
you've shown so far, the the, the, the,
the layer that shows the
massive burning of the forest,
the impact craters that we've found,
the nuclear glass,
the micro diamonds,
all this evidence that the,
in an immediate shift of the climate,
the mass extinction of a huge percentage
of the large mammals is the impact
period. That period. Is that
considered in mainstream science,
mainstream
science because it's mainstream
scientists who've presented the evidence,
as I said,
data that you've accumulated in correspond
comes from right from mainstream
science published in, in the
absolute leading scientific journals,
but you're stitching it together.
What, what nobody has done yet.
I think I'm probably the
first person to do it,
is to take that evidence and consider
its implications for the stories we tell
ourselves about the origins of
civilization. Very important story.
Where did civilization come from?
What is it?
And that information has not been taken
into account at all by archeologists yet
I hope they will do so in the future.
They need to play a very fast game of
catch up to catch up with the science on
this and take it into account.
But right now it's not being
taken into account at all.
You will not find a single archaeological
document which takes account of the
cataclysm that happened between twelve
thousand eight hundred and eleven
thousand six hundred years ago.
Big Part of the problem is specialization
in science. I think. So you've got, um,
you know, uh, paleontologists
looking at the extinction of ants.
You've got marine geologist
looking at sea level rise.
You've got glaciologists looking at how
the glaciers disappeared and we're in a
position now where we need to
begin synthesizing all this it,
you know what's interesting to
me though is that it, it really,
it almost falls on the shoulders
of the Mavericks, you know,
the synthesizers and that's kind
of really right now there's so much
specialization in science that the next
phase of it I think is beginning to
integrate it.
It takes to create a coherent model of
our past because a lot of like grandma's
saying, a lot of the mainstream
scientists have this information, right?
If I,
if,
if we look at this graph right here
and you see how this compares with, um,
the graphs we just saw of the climate
changes and the ocean level rise,
this is a, as it says, Lake
place to see mortality graph.
And this is basically looking
at radiocarbon dated a
fossilized remains of the
extinct mammals.
And if you look carefully,
you'll see that within the range that
we're talking about writing here,
here's your 13,000 year spike right here.
This is exactly the same time period.
And yeah,
exactly the same as the
changing of the temperature,
the rising of the sea levels,
massive extinction event, right,
and narratives right there.
Every one of these squares
represents a fossilized remain.
I think the 360 or 70
specimens that have been dated,
it seems insanely unlikely to me that
this didn't correspond with an impact on
human civilization. It's very, it's very
clear that it's a sense, it seems insane,
but it's not like mainstream and
consuming. If this is all fact,
and obviously it is,
how is this not like how hasn't it,
this is so glaring for something happen.
It raises a horrible
possibility for archaeology,
but they have been completely wrong
about the origins of civilization.
I mean not just slightly wrong but
completely wrong because they didn't take
account of this.
That's a horrible possibility and it's
much better to just try and get rid of
the data. I'm not saying that it's
a conspiracy by archaeologists.
I'm saying it's human nature.
If you're invested in a system of
ideas so powerfully invested in it,
that your own personality is
connected to you just can't accept it.
It's really hard to accept almost your
generation has to die off before a new
generation comes that will be prepared
to it. It was just with old age,
I'm not threatening and assault on
Ooh,
because it empowered. I think you're
right. Yeah. Yeah. And, and, and that's,
I think that's the problem why it's
not been taken and Randall's right.
The other problem is the intense
specialization of our society.
That's one of the
strengths of our society.
There's also one of the weaknesses or
society that everybody's really good at.
One particular thing.
That's the only way it all works out
because how one could possibly get all of
this work done and it's all we're all
into dependent upon upon one another.
But there's not enough comparing
notes across the disciplines.
And I guess that's where my skills
such as they are come in that I can,
I've spent my whole life synthesizing
data from, from many different fields.
And that's what, um, that's, that's,
that's what I'm doing here. And it also,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but it seems like there's a part of the
issue is there's no consequence to not
considering this stuff. There's no
consequence to just ignoring it.
They ignore it.
They team teach what they've
taught mainstream and they
still come out smelling
like a rose and everything
looks great. Exactly, and they,
and they all keep their jobs.
They don't annoy that colleagues.
It's almost the opposite of that because
to go here, they're actually, you know,
they're threatening your position.
You know, they're, they're, they're
putting their position in danger,
but I don't understand why they would
be because to me it seems like you would
want to say,
we have some exciting
hi data. So this is, well now we have
to reconsider what we already know.
We already know, you know, about this
part of the world and this was a,
we'd already know about
the pleistocene era.
We already know about all
these different houses,
but now we have this new data
to consider and hear all it is.
They should be excited about it.
They should be joyous, that there's,
this is something here, which really
could change the whole picture.
But that's not the case. It's, it's,
it's radically opposed. Well it just,
it makes your education look like shit.
I mean it's really unfortunate,
but it really does see this is an area
that Randall and I happen to know a lot
about.
What I wonder is in other areas that I
don't know about is this same phenomenon
at work,
that kind of knowledge filter,
which is just shutting us off from
what discipline would that be?
Or are you just social, social sciences,
any, any, any area of science, a medicine,
how things are to be done with,
with medicine,
how tumors are to be handled and
dealt with. You know, we have,
we have a dog my right now that it's
chemotherapy and radiotherapy and,
and every other system is, is regarded
as what pseudoscience generally.
But maybe that's a mistake.
You know,
maybe we should be considering
the possibility of these
alternative therapies.
Maybe they're better than blasting
somebody with highly radioactive material.
Well,
I certainly think there's some,
there's some things that we don't know
about the impact of nutrition and overall
health and meditation and just the
impact of stress and wellbeing and how it
plays on health factors.
And I think we're going to learn all that.
I mean I think there's probably
more discussion and more uh,
more focus on that then there is on stuff
like this, this sure, sure. There is.
Our personal health is
important to all of this and,
and this is kind of a part of our
personal health because it's a part of our
understanding of the we, our environment
that we exist in, where we are,
where we came from. Yeah,
absolutely. Now you got,
how long did you guys rode trip together?
It's about two weeks. Wasn't it?
Run a little shy of two weeks. And
what, what did, what did it entail?
Did you guys make a video of it or
anything? There was a lot of videos shot.
Beautiful. One of one of
rentals colleagues, Brad,
who was with us shut video along the way
and my wife's Santha took photographs
and you know, we've put, we've, we've
documented all of this very, very, very,
very thoroughly. But it was an amazing
road trip for me. It was the first time,
actually I've, I've driven
a great distance across the
continental United States.
I've always been in this city or that
city and picking up an airplane and going
here,
there,
but actually drive across this
incredible majestic land was,
it was an enormous experience
for me and it made me,
it filled me with a sense
of just how huge America is.
I live in this tiny island, you know,
Britain, but this giant, these open,
they open skies country that they
think they call it in there. It was,
it was a great initiation into,
into a beautiful part of North America
and a mysterious part of North America.
And it was great to do it with Randall
because he's been walking the walk in
this,
in this area for decades.
And he knows that landscape
like the back of his hand.
And for people that are listening
to this podcast right now.
And this is your first
introduction to Randall and Graham.
You gotta go pause right now
and go back to the first one.
Grandma's on the first one.
Randall was on and just do a binge,
just binge lists and our binge watch.
What are we looking at here? Well, this
is Graham. I'm trespassing. How dare you
can, I'm like, I'm watching it
all directions first and be there.
Well,
since the,
since the first time I was there at this
is grammar actually referred to this
erratic earlier. Um,
this was one of those,
that 18,000 ton boulder
sitting above what not.
So that was the boulder
that was pushed by the wind,
carried in ice and ice
chained in an ice burg. So
this massive rush of water had a giant
rocks embedded in the iceberg to float
that you need an ice bag about the
size of an oil tanker. And this is,
this is sitting 400 feet
above the Modern Day Columbia.
So we know that the water was
at least this height. Well,
actually it had to been higher than this
because 90% of the iceberg is under the
surface of the water. And how do we
know that this rock just wasn't there?
How do we know that it
was carried by this? Well,
because it's not part of the bedrock.
It's sitting on top of the land surface.
Like all of these. If we look
here, we've got some, some other,
do we know where it came from?
Do we know how far away it or originate?
It's probably come from about 50
miles to 75 miles north of here. It's,
it's the type of basalt it is,
is, is, has been identified.
I don't remember specifically,
but when you travel over this land,
you see these giant boulders just strewn
about as a place called bolded puck.
It's a tourist attraction now.
You want to see it? Yeah. Yeah.
And you can see there, I mean the
size of that in there. Let's see.
Oh my God. Yeah. So they just stand
out like out of nowhere. Yeah. And we,
we know this had to have
been transported a board,
an iceberg for the simple reason that if
it was carried within the glacier mass,
like a typical glacier erratic,
you wouldn't have those sharp
square corners like that. A glacier.
It gets ground off and oftentimes,
and this thing was transported almost 200
miles from its likely origin was Mount
Robeson and we didn't get to this one,
but this is evidence that the,
the flooding was much more extensive
than just the Missoula right flooding
because this is the Missoula flooding
that we were looking at was on the west
side of the North
American continental vice.
You just jump in there and say that
it isn't any longer controversial,
that there was gigantic flooding in the
Pacific northwest and then indeed across
the whole range, just south of the
ice cap, that that is accepted now.
But the very idea that there was
flooding a toll was hotly opposed for for
decades.
There was a great American
geologist called j Holland
brats who was the first to
document the fact that there had been
colossal flooding in that area and he
lived in the 19 hundreds had
19 1920s and he suggested
that there had been a cataclysm. Of
course, he was exiled by his colleagues.
Eventually his data prevailed and
he was awarded the Penn Rose Metal,
the highest award of the Geological Glg
in America in 1976 when he was like 96
years old, I must have sucked for.
And he said, then he said, he said,
all my enemies are dead,
so I have no one left to gloat over
what is so disturbing to me that it
works like that. It works like that.
But what happened,
you see was Harlan.
Brett's was convinced from the
beginning that he was dealing,
and this is a very experienced field,
geologists,
that he was dealing with a single
humongous flood which had risen and fallen
within perhaps two weeks.
That was his evidence on the ground
and he was attacked because people kept
saying, well, where did
the water come from?
You know what's the source of this water?
And he said, that's not my problem.
I am showing you the clear unmistakable
evidence of flooding on the ground.
Flooding happened.
Somebody else go work out where the
water came from and this stuck the whole
argument for the best part of 40
years until a compromise was reached.
And that's the word that Randall used.
Missoula,
they said that this flooding was caused
by outburst floods from a glacial lake
that's referred to as
Glacial Lake Missoula.
And because the flooding is so extensive,
it must have outburst 80 or 90 times
to cause to cause that flooding,
which completely contradicts Highland.
Brett's his view that it was a
two week flood, one single event,
but the compromise was accepted that the
cause of the flooding was glacial Lake
Missoula. That is now going to have to be
reviewed because of the comet evidence.
If Harlan Brett's of Jay Harlan breads
had had the information we have today,
he would have known instantly what caused
that single humongous flood and that
was the liquid dicing have a huge area
of the North American ice cap instantly.
And the floods that followed.
It's so fascinating that the,
the obsessions of a few people
come together like this.
And you can kind of piece these things
together on a podcast. We're on a,
what does this crazy imagery.
We out of a 19th century
text when catastrophism
before catastrophism had been
completely exorcised from
mainstream geology and this was, um,
uh, Louis figure I think was his
name, who speculated that the,
that the ice sheets over
Northwestern Europe had catastrophic.
He melted down and he had an
illustration in his geology text,
which perfectly captures how these larger
radix are actually being transported.
A board,
these icebergs.
And you can see the scale of the
thing and this is the kind of,
you see a whole forests are about to
be washed away here. And this, this,
this image. When the first time I saw
it, I thought, well, here it is. This,
this depicts the kind of field evidence
that we, we've been looking at here.
Um, so that's why I've included it here
because it helps to visualize what we're
talking about. Um, we've got some
intro. This was a place that,
and I visited here,
which really spectacularly
embodies this whole phenomena.
This is known as as dry faults cataract
and it's about five miles wide and I'm
going to show you the ground photographs
and a couple of aerial photographs of
it. She can kind of get
the scale of the thing.
Now this was the thing is
anybody can go there. This is,
this is on the lab hours to look at.
We won't go and see this amazing trip
to see it. You could go there, Joe.
They would let you in there to see this.
Where were you trespassing on that
particular shot? That that's huge.
18,000 ton boulder has is surrounded
by notices. We say no trespassing.
I trespassed,
I mean the thing is made at Bass Hall
and my footstep is not going to do any
harm. Yeah, I bet nobody even
noticed the Graham had been up there,
so it's not like a private property issue.
It's like they're just
trying to keep people.
I think it is actually a
private pro probably. Yes.
Because I have noticed from the first
time I went there, which was, gosh,
I don't know, 98, I think there
was no houses on that hillside.
Now the houses are moving up the hill
side spent development and so forth.
There was houses pretty
much right around it.
So we're going to overrun it and
there'll be no evidence you guys get to
accumulate your evidence. Why he came for
condos go up there. So that's awesome.
Right now, no. You'll notice
these, there's a series of
these alcoves here that,
that you know,
these,
these horseshoe shape on the image of
dry falls back on the image of dry false.
Exactly. And, and at some point somebody
is going to be able to see these images,
right? Yeah. Well people could
go and Google them online,
but they'll see them right now on youtube
if they watched the youtube versus
tube. Okay. So here's a typical
horseshoe falls of Niagara, which is,
which is a modern, uh, cataract,
receding cataract. And this,
this horseshoe shape is very typical of
the way water will erode bedrock because
water flows faster in
the middle of the stream.
Therefore it roads faster in the middle
and not so much as you get towards the
margins. And so it creates this
classic horseshoe shape profile.
And that's what we're
seeing here at dry falls.
Now this is just one of the alcoves of
about half a dozen of the alcoves that we
saw in the map of it.
How the words,
this is a monstrously big
waterfall. Yes. Now try today,
just off to the left of the
picture is where I'm actually in.
There's a photograph in
Graham's book taken, um, from,
let's go back. We skipped
over it. There it is.
This is the viewpoint and
this is horseshoe falls of
Niagara superimposed on dry
fall. She can get a sense of the
scale. So Niagara Falls is a tiny,
tiny little thing by comparison with
this ancient fossilized waterfall,
which dates back 12,000,
800 years.
Niagara Falls is the result of 12,000
or more years of work of the river.
Dry falls between upper and lower at
grand coulee in Washington state is the
result of two weeks of flooding.
What? Yeah. And for people, look,
he's trying to explain this
for people that are, because
it's, it's probably 10 times bigger plus
more than that. How many, how many times?
It's two and a half times as
high and well figure this, the,
the discharge over of the Niagara River
over the falls is a couple of hundred
thousand cubic feet per second maximum.
The discharge over Grand
Cooley was somewhere between
300 and 400 million cubic
feet per second or another words somewhere
between 10 and 20 times the combined
flow of every river on
earth flowing all at once.
And the height of this scarf face here,
this cliff is about 400 feet.
The water coming over
was about 400 feet deep.
So if you are here,
visualize seat witnessing
this at the peak of the flood,
you wouldn't in fact even see a waterfall.
What you would see is this massive
10 mile wide turgid river choked with
icebergs and debris and whole
forest river flowing at what?
60 70 miles an hour,
60 70 miles an hour.
What you would've seen here was just a
bump in this flood and then only at the
latter stages of it where did
actually have been a waterfall as the,
as the water source was dissipating
and as the water was declining,
you would have the final
stage of it being a waterfall.
Then eventually the waterfall stopped.
And what you have today is this
fossilized feature of this massive,
and this is only one of about a half
a dozen comparable sized cataracts.
We didn't get to see potholes or Frenchmen
Cooley next time perhaps I did a j
anybody listening to this,
if he can do so,
get up to Washington state and go
visit upper and lower at grand coulee.
It's as a stunning, stunning landscape
is a great trip to make. And, and,
and you can see the evidence on the,
on the ground and you know,
people don't know about, you know,
we've got like here, this is Utah.
And what you see here is once you begin
to understand the cataract formation
and, and you understand the
morphology of a cataract,
you're looking at something like this
in which we're looking at is cataracts
extinct, cataracts out in Canyon Lands,
Utah and they're massively scaled.
But no geologists. See,
here's the problem.
Geologists haven't been focused on
catastrophism what they've been doing.
They worked for the government, they
worked for the oil companies. They,
they're more interested
in what's down below that.
The match will gas the oil and stuff.
There's another point,
there's another point I'd
like to add to that, Randall,
as to why geologists and not
a focused on catastrophes. Uh,
geology is a science and science in
effect defined itself as being different
from religious superstition.
So the notion of the great flood that
we find in the Bible became a very
discredited notion in science and,
and the bye bye bye bye association with
any suggestion of a great cataclysm in
the past was seen as superstitious
behavior to be completely
by the squeaky clean, shiny new sciences
who must never take that into account.
So any geologist good dares to propose.
A cataclysmic episode is up against that
right away that his colleagues don't
want to go there because they're afraid
that they're going to be accused of
buying into Noah's flood or whatever.
That's so unfortunate, but it's true and,
and this is the, this is
the problem. So there's,
there's catastrophism and
uniformitarianism and the
prevailing dogma in geology
is the uniformitarian dogma,
which is basically to say the way
we see things in the world today.
That's how it's always been.
It's never been any change.
So random. What is the mainstream
understanding of those, those,
those formations? Like what? When they
look at those, the Utah ones, for example,
gigantic Utah. I have searched
and searched and I find nothing.
They just don't explain it. They
don't explain skull. Oh look,
how pretty do you think of the
flooding went as far South as Utah?
Not directly glacial.
I think what we're looking there,
it has to be torrential rain.
Right?
Which was, which is another association
of this, of this impact picture.
This huge impacts on the ice cap.
An enormous amount of,
of watery material is thrown up into
the, into the atmosphere, not only water,
but also mud and,
and you get this rain out,
which comes down for a
long period after that.
And I'm not necessarily saying that
all of that was stripped in one event
because the place to seen is basically
two and a half million years,
two point I think 2.6 million
is the latest dating of it.
And there's been probably a dozen or two
dozen ice ages that have come and gone.
To me, the evidence I'm seeing suggests
that the transition from glacial to
interglacial and back again is
not a smooth process. In fact,
it's probably highly catastrophic,
um,
not necessarily as catastrophic as
the event we're talking about 12,000,
800 years ago,
but certainly catastrophic enough that
we're an event of equivalent magnitude to
happen today. We could maybe
not cause a mass extinction,
but we could certainly pull the
plug on modern civilization. Um,
and so this, this picture is interesting
because what it does is it, it,
it shows that, you know, you
travel over the, this landscape.
Explain them what this picture
is and where's the cake?
You know, now this is, um,
this is in,
uh,
western Montana and this is place
called dry creek. And what this is,
is just a gravel pit.
But what you see here is deposits caused
by searching floodwaters moving up
tributary valleys loaded with sediment.
And one of the things that is stratego
for a sedimentologist looks at is you
notice how they're tilted. You see how
the, the, the layers are tilted, okay?
That's an indication of which
direction the water is moving.
The tilting goes down in the
direction that the water is flowing.
So what we see here is massive
turbulent sediment laden floodwaters
back flooding up a valley,
surging, leaving deposits,
and then flowing back out,
followed by another wave,
followed by another wave for now,
for 13,000 years,
12,000 years,
this material has been laying there and
you see that there's forests growing
over it,
okay?
People traveling over this landscape
don't see what's under their feet,
you see?
But once you get an outcrop like this
and you understand and you can read what
you're seeing here, then suddenly
it becomes apparent that the,
that the very hills and landscape,
that work that we live on,
that we've built our cities on and our
highways and that were playing out all
these dramas that right under our feet
is the evidence of previous worlds.
You have to understand that what you're
looking at there is the debris of a
former world that was pulverized by
these floods carried in and deposited and
now a new world has emerged out of that.
And on top of this wreckage
does room forma world existed,
I believe on advanced civilization.
That is memoralized and myths
and traditions all around
the world that is being
ridiculed by archeologists,
but it is insistent and the
evidence keeps on coming forward.
Well, it all makes sense.
It really does. It's,
it's all shocking and
stunning and fantastic,
but it all makes sense. I
think it does make sense. And,
and, and I think it's, it's,
it's something as part
of the human heritage,
it's something that we all have
to get to grips with. Again,
this is one of the things
I find in encouraging about
developments in the world
today is that more and more people do
appear to be thinking for themselves.
You know,
that there was a time when we,
we took the word of specialists,
Dr [inaudible] or professor,
why said this had to be true.
Uh,
that was so actually when I wrote
fingerprints of the Gods in 1995,
that was the first argument
was the argument from
authority. The authorities say,
this cannot be so
therefore it does not sell.
And a lot of people just just bolt that.
What's changed,
I think in the last 20 years
is that, that, that, that, um,
subservience to authority has gone away.
It hasn't gone away completely,
but we don't trust authority anymore,
rightly and properly because we've
been lied to by authority figures.
And we know they lied to
us and we saw the evidence,
whether it's politicians or
big corporations, you know
what the big religions,
the, the, there's a,
there's an uprising against this and an
assertion of individual will and, and,
and have individual intellect
to inquire into the past.
And I think that that's why this,
this information now has, uh, is,
is coming at a time where it's falling on,
on fertile ground.
There will still be a
lot of resistance to it.
We can expect that resistance
to be fearless and to go on,
but things are shifting in the world
just as our picture of the past is
shifting.
So our picture of who we are and what
we're meant to be doing here is shifting
as well. Have you guys thought about
coming together and doing a documentary?
I'd love to do a documentary around it.
Do you guys together? It's a must do.
I mean, it just seems like the book
is, I'm sure going to be fantastic,
but there's going to be people that
are just not going to read a book and
documentaries are so easy or you just
do is open your stupid mouth, lay down,
you know, turn on Netflix and
Bam, you know, you can absorb it.
It's highly visual material and it's
visual and it's just what I'm saying.
It's so visual and the two of you
together, we need a crowdfund something.
Can I make an appeal?
It's the first time I've ever done this.
It's a kind of loose ditch.
It's a little pitch. Okay.
I've never asked for this before,
but what I'm,
what I'm asking to those who value and
appreciate my work and feel that I'm
doing something useful in the world,
please support my work by getting this
book because that is the best way to put
one finger up to the mainstream.
Archeology wants this book to go away.
They want it to be forgotten.
It will never be reviewed
in any mainstream newspaper.
It will never be written about.
There will be no articles about it and
probably know television coverage either.
The only thing that can make
the difference is people
voting with their feet and
um, I'm asking that now are people that
thought in my work, people are huge,
huge fans of your
appearance is here and huge,
huge fans of your work and if this is,
this is the latest and greatest,
I'm sure people are going
to go out and buy in droves,
so magicians of the gods
and get it on Amazon.
You can get it on your website and get
it pretty much everywhere that I go to my
website and all the,
all the links and the whole,
the whole background on the
on on the book is there. I,
I hugely appreciate,
deeply appreciate the support
that my readers have given me.
I would be nothing without my readers.
And that's why every time I do an event,
I sit there for two to three hours
afterwards talking to people and signing
books because the readers are the most
important people in my, in, in my,
in my universe. And there, there Wa
there who give me strength without,
without my readers. I'm literally
nothing and I value and appreciate them.
And I'm on a journey across America
now and I'm speaking in many,
many different cities and the
whole program is up on my website,
on the talks and events page and make
sure we tweaked that stuff and get that
information now.
And I'll get that information out for
the entirety of the time you're here.
Just let me know where you're going
to be and I'll let everybody know when
you're going to be there. Since we're
plugging, I'd like to plug, I got this.
What is that? Well, it's a a about a four
and a half hour presentation. Of course,
loads of graphics, um, radio clips,
animations, and it's all
you. Yeah. And what does it,
was it called cosmic patterns
and cycles of catastrophe? Well,
we can go go to the sacred
geometry international website,
or I think Cameron wheelchair who
you're Novak who introduced us, um,
has a, I think he's doing
a special on it. No. Okay.
33% off or something. What does the
actual URL of the website? Well,
it would be sacred geometry,
international.com. There it is.
Jamie's pulled it up right there. So
cosmic patterns and cycles of Catastrophe.
Yes. 33.33% off. What does that all about?
Don't have to ask Cameron
about that and some,
some hidden numerology in
there somewhere apparently.
And you'll notice coupon code
magicians. Ah, there you go.
Magicians of the gods must be a reference.
I think it'd probably corresponds. Um,
so I, I really think that you guys have
to do one of these things together as a
documentary. I mean, I think it's
just, I think someone out there,
someone's listening to this,
probably some kooks that we don't
want doing this documentary,
but there's gotta be somebody out there
that's legit when you need to find them
and put it together. Yeah. I wanted to pay
tribute to Randall's work, right. Rent.
Randall is really important figure
in this field. And he's very,
he's very modest and he's been standing
back and, and you know, he's not,
not been out there enough.
It's time that people understood the
fantastic knowledge that this man has and
they, the, the ground experience.
You can't beat that. Well,
I met Randall in cows early
two thousands, right? I, well,
when, when you were at the
punchline. Yeah. And Atlanta,
which doesn't even exist anymore.
10 years ago, I think it was,
it was quite awhile ago. And, uh, we had
this conversation after my show and he's,
we were just sitting there talking to
me about the Holocene and all of these
different impacts.
And I remember walking away from it.
We talked for quite a while after
the show, but I remember going,
that might be the craziest fucking post
show conversation I've ever had because
usually, you know, after a comedy show
you have a conversation with people,
you know, hey, where's a good
place to eat? You know, a,
if you do, you like Atlanta,
you know,
normal stuff.
And he's just flooding me with
information. I'm like, who is this guy?
Well, I remember walking
away from it going, wow,
I had no idea that Joe Rogan really
related to all this stuff, you know? Oh,
I was fascinated.
I was surprised something there,
which is I'd like to say something
about you, Joe. Um, it's a phenomenon.
I traveled all around the world
and I give presentations in,
in just countries everywhere
and everywhere I go,
people come up to me and they said,
Joe Rogan sent this to you.
We know about your work because of,
because of Joe Rogan.
And I see that what you're
doing is exploring many,
many controversial areas in your,
in your show,
you're in a position of
power and your listeners,
just as my readers on my strength,
your listeners or your strength,
they've put you in a position of power,
but you're a person who's using that
power for something really good.
There are so many people who are powerful
in the world of the media who just
wasted away on Trivia and nothing.
You are bringing new information
to people all around the world.
And I can tell you, cause I meet
them every time I give an event.
You are enormously appreciated.
Well I appreciate them very much and I
appreciate you guys and I appreciate this
show because this, this whole thing
came about without any planning.
This show just sort of became itself.
It's almost like I was a,
I would just happen to be there
to germinate it or something.
I just tried to get out of my own
way as much as possible and follow my
curiosity.
And the beautiful thing about people like
you guys is without you take away you
and fingerprints of the gods takeaway you.
And what are we looking at?
I mean is it's very rare when you have
two human beings that without them an
entire field of study would be barren
of a great deal of its information.
I mean you have John Anthony
West and Robert Schoch who,
and you were obviously a part of all that.
And John Anthony West who's
absolutely fascinating,
fascinating guy and another guy.
Why did Lima line a guy who's ignored
but magical Egypt is one of the greatest
DVD series to this day that
I've ever seen in my life.
And if you've got the time
and the attention span to
sit down and watch all of
them, it is amazing. Amazing.
John Anthony West is one of my
favorite people on the plant.
He's incredibly brilliant researcher.
John more than anybody else who opened my
mind to the mysteries of ancient Egypt.
Fantastic work. And he's a world treasure.
He is a will treasure. He's a great,
great, great man. And I
think that DVD series is, uh,
is just one pedal when unfolding of the
great flower of information that you
guys are presenting. And I think, and
another name, I'll drop it in there,
which is Robert Bovard. They
originated. Yeah, Ron Gosh.
He's done so much to bring back attention
to the importance of the skies and the
HR world and what it means for our
understanding of our past. And again,
his evidence also points back to
this period of 12,800 years ago.
And while we're at it,
Robert Schoch early stock stuck his neck
out from Boston University and really
one of the first mainstream scholars
that went out on a limb and said,
we are absolutely
looking at water erosion.
Robert Shuck is a key figure in this
field. He's very courageous to have to,
to be a mainstream academic,
to be a professor of geology at Boston.
It was John West who introduced Robert
Schoch to the notion that the Sphinx
might be much older, that the
weathering on it didn't fit with the,
with the picture of history at John took
Robert Shuck to Egypt and Robert Shuck
went with the data and he stuck his neck
out and he's taken a lot of criticisms
and tax for it. But he's a very, very
important player in this field. Well,
all of you guys are just massively,
massively important and this is such a
unique and satisfying object of curiosity
for me at least when when I start
thinking about these things,
it's almost like little things start
firing off in my brain. It's so,
it's so exciting.
I mean it's horrific to think about the
poor people that lived back then that
got hit by these massive impacts
and the the, the, this, the,
the aftermath of it all.
It must've been insane.
But to think about now in 2015 the
slow unveiling of all of this data and
information and he has you
as it all gets into focus
and you try to get a clearer and
clearer view of what could have possibly
happened in the past.
I find it so incredibly
enriching and fascinating to me.
One of the most exciting aspects of,
of the the,
there's the potential of archeology. Yeah.
Just to, to be able to discover like, oh,
that's what happened.
Ah, kind of Aha moment.
Suddenly the pieces fall into place and
we understand what we forgot and again,
it's cement.
That statement that you
made that resonated with me
that we are a civilization
with amnesia. We just knocked
on the head and we lost a lot.
I lost a lot of them, but there is that
haunting sense of incompleteness within,
within so many of us that
comes from that loss of memory.
I feel like any amnesiac has a sense
of something missing whole species.
How that,
I think what makes this really so potent
is the fact that there are considerable
implications for our own future. Oh,
absolutely. You know how Graham wraps up
the book really is, is about our future,
you know, and, and once,
now that we've integrated this
information into our world view, you know,
what does it imply in terms of,
of where we go from here because one of
the things that I track and if you could
shut the, throw this up on
a screen for just a second,
I'm going to speed through something
really quick here so that you can kind of
get the impression 1989, 1989. Let me get,
um, let me just, you
giant asteroid Mace, close call by
Earl Randall's fixing that. Let's also,
let's also remind that we had a close,
relatively close pass with
a half kilometer wide,
actually bit of a comet, uh,
just over Halloween.
Um,
and the interesting thing is that NASA
only found that object on the 10th of
October and it okay,
it missed us.
It passed about the distance of the moon
from the earth. That's not that far.
That's not that far.
But the key thing is,
the key thing is that they only
found it a few days before it passed.
And how many other objects are out and
about half a kilometer wide hospital over
to why?
So the one that hit tongue goose
car was 100 meters to tiny.
This is a minimum,
a minimum of 150 to 200 times
the volume of turn goose.
And when you look at the universe
and just look at our galaxy,
the size of our galaxy,
and look at our solar system,
the size of our solar system, that is
literally like getting grazed by a bullet.
It's like getting great.
Absolutely.
That's a good analogy is a
really good analogy. When
you think about it, you know,
you'd say, well, a half a kilometer
compared to the earth, that's not big.
But like when you know, you think,
think of a, a slug from,
uh, from uh, uh, 32, right?
If I threw it at you and hit you with it,
it wouldn't do much.
But if I accelerate it to
a thousand feet per second,
it's going to cause extreme trauma,
right?
But now we're looking at these asteroids
flying and comment debris and there 10
times,
20 times the speed of a rifle bullet when
they hit our atmosphere like you know,
50 60 70,000 miles per hour and the the,
the kinetic punch of something
like that is inconceivable.
It's like Graham said,
I mean to talk about it,
you'd have to take our
entire nuclear arsenal of,
of the peak of the Cold War,
detonate it all at once and even that
would only be a fraction of the forces
unleashed. Nope. No. Watch this.
I'm going to go through this real,
real quick here and you'll
get the idea, I think, um,
that we're,
we're at,
because astronomers are looking out into
our cosmic environment and this is what
they're seeing. Look at this lights only
back here is most of us are listening.
Nine objects have come close
to the earth since 1991.
Right?
Current pre read that asteroid
estimates are too low.
This was October of 2000 current
predictions for the number of potentially
dangerous,
sorry.
Dangerous Asteroids have
been underestimated by at
least 20% say astronomers
according to re recent calculations
there between 750 and 900 asteroids.
Let me circling the earth. That number
has changed. That reports from October,
2000 we're now looking at the estimates
and now that it's 100,000, uh,
potentially earth destroying objects
that are on earth crossing orbits.
This isn't,
this is an estimate.
The problem is NASA has only identified
a tiny fraction of what's out there.
And again, I'm not saying this cause
I want to spread gloom and doom.
I'm saying this,
I'm saying this because we have the
capacity to do something about it, right?
It takes goodwill on the part of the human
race to stop wasting money on stupid,
stupid pursuits,
particularly warfare.
And to apply that resource,
those resources to sweeping,
clean our cosmic environment,
the technology already exists.
It's going to cause a,
I mean it's going to have to be,
there's going to have to be a
massive shift in our attention.
Like there has to almost be an event that
takes place that makes people wake up.
Right. We have world asteroid day right
now. Some prominent figures in behind it,
like Brian May, I think it was
one of the guitarists with Queen,
if I remember correctly. There's,
there's a there, there, there,
there is publicity around
so-called world asteroid day,
but nobody's taking it seriously.
We don't take anything
seriously unless it's smacks us.
Like people don't quit
cigarettes until they get cancer.
There's something about human beings
that we don't consider the pos.
We have this idea in our head that we're
eternal and we're going to live forever
and everything's gonna be fine.
Just I just need a new Lexus.
You know what I mean?
Well, you have this wacky,
I just need this watch that I've added
my eye on this laptop that I want to buy
it.
If something happened,
if a massive collision hit China.
Yeah.
And it wiped out like several million
people and then cause the earth to go into
nuclear winter and crops died and we
experiment experience global famine,
then something like that, then we
would wake up and go, all right Russia,
let's talk,
let's get together.
I'm hoping that it doesn't take
anything quite that extreme.
If we had a repeat of tin goose can 1908,
I think that would be enough to do it.
That would be nice.
But would it be because there was this
incident in Russia that was last year.
There was caught on all those
dashboard cameras. Yeah.
Where's the wonderful thing about Russia?
It's apparently there's so
much like insurance crime
and so many collisions with
each other that a lot of people over
in Russia have dash cam. Okay. Right.
I was wondering why.
So because of those dash cams,
that's how we have all this footage
of these, these meteors that,
that uh, blew up in the
atmosphere and didn't even land.
But we have some from inside schools
where people were watching like this thing
happened and go down and that
was nothing. And now, yeah,
there was a fraction of the size of the
Tunguska event, but nobody was killed.
You see if, if that object had
been a little bigger, if it's been,
if it's a PR,
a little or the little dancer,
it's angle of approach
had been a little steeper.
You might've been looking at 1500
deaths rather than just 1500 injuries.
I think that would have been
a wake up call. Perhaps.
Maybe not enough to reorient civilization,
but I guarantee you a tongue goose go
event over a major inhabited area of the
globe wiping out a million people.
I,
I can't imagine that that wouldn't have
some kind of a effect on our attitude
towards our are in our vulnerability in
the cosmos and make people think maybe
there's something bigger we need to be
paying attention to here rather than,
you know, um, Kardashians
melting vulnerable.
This is the illusion created by,
by modern technology.
We need to make a war on asteroids.
Like we have a war on terror. You know,
Congress,
we'll just
kind of at least that would
be a useful project yes. Is,
is to actually do something that could
benefit and say human race instead of
Moses profitable and hatred.
But see that's the thing.
These asteroids are actually
extraordinary sources of resources,
natural resources,
platinum group metals and hydrocarbons
and water and precious metals.
All of these things that we're mining
from the earth now exist in those
asteroids that are threatening the planet.
And we're not that far away from being
able to develop the technologies in the
industries to actually go and rendezvous
with an asteroid. Of course it's, it's,
it's a matter of, like Graham was saying,
I mean this last Halloween asteroid,
they didn't find it, but a couple of
weeks before it passed by the earth.
So we need a lot more,
um,
capabilities of seeing what's out there.
Um,
and we're developing that
but at a very slow pace.
So there are practical suggestions
that come out of all of this.
This isn't just about the past.
As Randall said,
this is also about the future of the
human race and what we do and how we,
how we live on this, on this gorgeous
planet that the universe gave us and,
and how we pay back for being given
that opportunity. And so the, the
current ideas are to somehow or another
nudge these asteroids out of the way.
Well,
10 different technologies to do it.
What you don't really want to do is to
blow it up with the nuclear, right? Right.
Because then you get back shot
instead of a single bullet.
Buckshot can do a lot of harm as well
and it may even push it into a more
catastrophic orbit. So you don't want to
do that. But what you can do, for example,
is to change the reflectivity of one
side of the asteroid or comet fragments.
Uh,
you can alter that effectively,
paint it and that affects
the sun's radiation upon it.
And that would be enough to shift
it slightly out of its course.
There are a lot of,
there are a lot of techniques and
suggestions or nudges that this is you.
You put your finger on
exactly the right word.
This is another of the technologies that
you just nudge these things you just
don't need.
You just don't need to do much and you
put them into a safe place instead of a
dangerous place.
Czar idea that there's
hundreds of thousands of
killers out there and you just
have to excuse me from over there please.
A little bit of this and then also
we have to look out for all of them.
The ones that are coming from down there,
the ones that are coming from up here,
three dimensional space. That
got a real, I have to think of,
because when we look at the sky,
oh,
hope and asteroids not coming
our way from where fucker.
You know the last thing is crazy and is
it coming from the direction of the sun
so that we can see it
except very special camera.
That was the case with tin
goose. It came out. In fact,
if you read the eyewitness accounts,
they describe how it looks like was
being disgorged from to Sun. Oh.
Are being expelled from to or
was like a second son in the sky.
And that was because that,
that um,
summertime towards stream is coming
from behind the sun. Yeah. And um,
and so yeah, you can't see him if
because of the gravity of the sun,
the mass of the sun. Doesn't that affect
how we see things behind it anyway? Yeah,
it should do, it should
warps it warps vision. Yeah.
So like something could be coming
from behind the sun and we, we,
we literally would not even see it because
of the mass and gravity of the sun if
it was in the right area.
Can Goucho was not seen really
until it came into the atmosphere,
maybe into the atmosphere.
But that was obviously a long time
ago and there was not nearly as much
observation. The skies as
there are today. Right.
These are the, um, the steps
that we, we, we, we need to take.
We need to grow up as a,
as a species when you leave our,
our childhood a bit behind.
It's interesting to speculate
what would happen if we had,
uh,
impacts on the scale that happens 12,800
years ago and I'm pretty sure that it
would mean if it,
if it were allowed to happen,
that it would mean the end
of our civilization. This,
this civilization would
go down. This is a very intensely
specialized civilization.
I think the,
the just in time principle is that we
have two day or three day food supply in
our cities.
You interrupt that and you have a
kind of walking dead scenario within,
within a week. You know, it's
that it's that bad. There's this,
this civilization is,
appears to be very strong,
but in fact it's very fragile
and it could easily fall apart.
And so many of us in the
western technological world
actually have no survival
skills whatsoever.
We don't know how to survive because we
depend for our survival upon the complex
network of society.
Who would survive.
A cataclysm like that would
be the hunter gatherers,
people like the hunter gatherers of
the Kalahari in southern Africa or the
hunter gatherers of the Amazon Basin.
You know, the meek of the world.
Those who are not taken into
account in the world at all today.
They're the ones equipped both with the,
the the knowledge and the psychological
resources to deal with a situation like
that and to carry the human story forward.
And I just want to make sure,
if I can,
if I can play some part in this,
I just want to make sure
that the descendants of
those hunter gatherers 10,000
years in the future are not remembering
faintly and vaguely a great lost
civilization and magical civilization,
which had the ability to go to the moon,
which had the ability to,
one person could speak to another person
on the other side of the planet and
magical,
magical powers which was destroyed
because of its own arrogance and cruelty.
And that lost civilization
of course would be us. Well,
one of the things has been disturbing
me as I got older is the idea of print
about, uh, books,
sort of going away and everything is
becoming digital and digital to the form
that you can only read with an operating
system and a computer and a CPU and all
that jazz. If without all that, it's
nothing. It's not look at a hard drive.
It's just there's nothing there.
Just electrons take away,
take away the software and it'll
never be read again. Yeah. And what,
what evidence would there be a thousand
years from now of us if something were
to happen? It might be anybody might be
some weed. No, they were computer disks,
but the descendants of that time
would have no idea what they were.
And even if they did,
they'd have no way of accessing and
a thousand years from now they would
deteriorate to nothing. Anything,
nothing. All the plastic would be gone,
everything. It would just be
a complete, a complete mess.
That's where I look at megalithic
stone architecture is being a textbook.
Yeah. That's how you might
preserve things in another way.
You might preserve things if you're
developed a mythology around this whole
scenario and then you projected it onto
the night sky so that generations later
they would tell these
tales based upon the,
the mythological figures
juxtaposed on the night sky.
And there would be the story because it's
there. It's, it's all the whole mythos.
Western mythology has been
juxtaposed onto the fixed stars.
And so that's one way perhaps of,
of preserving information. Um,
and the other way I think is,
is massive stone architecture.
So it's clearly not an accident
that the great pyramid in codes,
the dimensions of our planet
routine close to them. You, you,
you measured the base perimeter of the
Great Pyramid and multiply it by 43,200
and you get the equatorial circumference
of the earth. Why that number? The well,
that's the key thing. And I'll come
to that in a second. If I may. Uh,
you take the height of the great pyramid,
multiply that by 43,000,
200 and you get the polar radius of the
earth. Actually Egypt told to know this,
but they say it's a complete coincidence
cause what's the significance of the
number 43,200 but actually it's
a highly significant number.
It's a number that is found embedded
in mythology all around the world.
And it is a multiple of the number 72
it's actually 600 times 72 and 72 is the
heartbeat of the processional cycle.
One degree of change every 72 years.
So what they've actually done is they've
given us the dimensions of our planet
on a scale defined by
emotion of the planet itself.
And that in my shoe is incredibly clever
way to pass information down to the
future.
That way they can be sure that any
astronomically literate society could work
this out. The information would be
there. So in all those dark ages,
when we had no knowledge that
we even lived on a planet,
or what its dimensions where those
dimensions were encoded into the enduring
structure of the Great Pyramid
of monument as the Arab say,
that time itself would fear
the great pyramids themselves.
The Great Pyramid of Giza in particular
is so spectacular that it almost,
it almost makes you go, man, there
had to be something going on there.
Then we must be missing
part of this picture.
Cause you're talking about
something that would be,
I've heard people say we could
reproduce it today. Of course we could.
And of course we could.
We can.
Can you make a stone that's the size of
one of the stones in the Great Pyramid?
Yes. Yeah. Well then we can make the
pyramid, but how long would it take? Yeah.
How hard would it be and where would be
the will and you'd have to be perfect.
Yeah. In order to get it to line up at
the top. The way it sets. Yeah, exactly.
You can't be off by a fraction of an inch,
otherwise you have a corkscrew instead
of a pyramid. That's the, that's,
that's the, the, the whole problem.
No, it's a, it's an amazing device.
A multifunctional device in, in my view,
in, in coding and coding knowledge,
but also working on, on
human consciousness. I,
I've had the privilege to be
alone inside the great pyramid.
Not surrounded by hundreds of others.
And as the silence descends,
this sense of intelligence
seems to come out from the wall.
Something is speaking to you there.
And I think that partly what it was
designed to do was to affect human
consciousness. And in a
weird way, it's still doing.
So it's just getting
people majestic structure,
just being so magnificent and
incredible that you just go whoa.
And also the sensory deprivation
element, you know, you're, you're
inside the so called King's chamber,
which had nothing to do with any king.
This amazing granite geometrical room,
300 feet above the ground in
the heart of the great pyramid.
As that silence descends, you feel
this monument begin to speak to you.
It's almost like it's shy. Put 50 people
in there and the dialogue goes away,
be in there alone, listen to the silence
and it starts to speak. Wow. Wow,
that's amazing.
It's just,
it's such a special
thing that we have this,
this area where you can see
these ancient structures and,
and causes your mind to wander and
think about these things and these
possibilities.
And when you add that to
all the information that you
guys have accumulated over
the course of your study and your
research, it's just an amazing,
amazing thing to consider.
I should mention another site
which we've not talked about today,
which is good in Padang, in
Indonesia. Uh, and again,
I have a couple of chapters on this in
the, in the new book good in Padang, uh,
is a man they pyramid. Um,
and it's been found about 30,
uh, about three hours drive west of
Bandung on the island of Java. Uh,
and for a long time it was thought to
be a relatively young megalithic site.
There's a megalithic site on top of what
was thought to be a natural hill, uh,
but now, uh, an amazing Indonesia
and geologists called Danny Hilman,
Natalie Georgia, uh, has
been over it with his team.
They've done ground penetrating radar
and seismic tomography on the whole
structure and they've also put drill
cores down into it and they have pulled up
remnants of manmade material associated
with dateable organic material that goes
back 20,000 years.
It goes back right into the last ice age.
This is a 20,000 year old pyramid sitting
in Indonesia and it's one of the most
exciting breaking stories in archaeology.
And typically because the discovery
work has been done by a geologist,
Indonesian archaeologists are
wanting the whole work stopped.
So this is it right here. Ah, that's not
good and down. No, no. It says about the,
the, the, the, the, those are good and
put down, not the, so the, so for example,
third from the right third from the
left. I mean that one. Yeah, that's the,
that's the known megalithic site on
top of what is now understood to be a
completely manmade pyramid.
We're,
so this is accepted only by geologists,
not by archeologist.
The archeologist say, oh, we know
that site. It's 2,500 years old.
There's nothing of interest there.
We would like the resources that are
being spent on this to be spent on our
projects instead.
And in fact,
they've lobbied with the Indonesian
government and the excavations have been
temporarily halted. Uh, I think that it
will go ahead again. I think what it,
what is the evidence that shows where's
the geological evidence and shows that
this is first, first of all,
the ground penetrating radar.
That picture of what is inside this
shows us that it is a manmade hill,
not a natural hill.
Secondly,
that it contains three
large chambers within it.
One of them at least as large as the
king's chamber in the Great Pyramid,
huge cavities, regular in shape,
which have not yet been excavated. Um,
and,
and thirdly,
that the date of this site
puts us back to 20,000 years,
right to the last glacial maximum when
Indonesia didn't look at tall the way it
looks today.
Indonesia 20,000 years ago was part of
a giant continent that geologists called
call a Sundar Sundar land, the Sunda
Shelf, uh, that it wasn't a peninsula,
the Malaysian peninsula and the
thousand islands of Indonesia.
It was a massive landmass and that land
mass was submerged predominantly between
twelve thousand eight hundred eleven
thousand six hundred years ago.
This site sits in an area of high land,
which was never submerged.
And it looks to me, again,
I'm speculating because the
excavation has been stopped,
but it looks to me as does go directly
Tepi like it, like a time capsule.
Something that takes us back
to that earlier period. And,
and in fact when we're looking
for a lost civilization,
I think we should be
looking all over the world.
Plato made it clear that Atlantis
wasn't just the island, it was a,
it had projected it's power
all around the world. Uh,
Indonesia is a very fruitful
area for further investigation.
And I did a huge research
trip in Indonesia and I
saw megaliths that had just
unaccounted for.
The archeology has never been done.
There's a giant megalithic culture in
that, in that island. And it's very cool.
Some cultures on Indonesia are still
making megaliths today. They're,
they're still doing it. It, it
continues this ancient tradition.
So when we're looking at this, what
are you, what are you guys saying?
I'm seeing a hill. I sing a
bunch of rocks. Yeah. Those.
That bunch of rocks is
the known Megalithic site,
which has correctly been
dated to 2,500 years ago.
It's what you say megalithic site.
This is a material called columnar battle,
which forms of forms naturally,
by the way,
into into regular patterns.
The giant's causeway in Ireland is a
columnar battled columnar basle when it,
it forms naturally forms
in vertical formations.
It's a very useful building material.
It can be broken up into blocks and when
you see them laid out horizontally like
this,
you know absolutely that human beings
have been involved and that they have made
this site.
But what's really interesting is what's
underneath what we're seeing there.
What's been revealed by the
ground penetrating radar
and the drill cores that is,
that is really fascinating because
that has not been taken into account by
archeology at all and that's
where we need to do this work.
If we're going to recover our lost pass,
Indonesia is one of the
places we need to be doing it.
Sort of someone like me
that's looking at this,
I'm just seeing a bunch of stones.
Yeah, that's what you're seeing.
So 2,500 year old site.
But what it appears to be the case that
that site was put there because there
was an ancient memory that this
was a sacred site. The word,
the name Gunung Padang in the Indonesian
language doesn't seem to mean very
much.
It means mountain,
but in the sooner knees language,
which is the language that is
spoken around Gunung Padang,
what Gunung Padang means is
mountain of enlightenment.
Whoa suggestion that it's connected
to an ancient system of knowledge.
It's one of many sites that are appearing
around the world now that don't fit
with the mainstream picture.
So this sort of parallel,
some of the ideas about the old kingdom
in Egypt and the ancient structures
where the new structures are built on
top of them and as they dig deeper into
the sand, they find different construction
methods that represent an older tire.
Exactly, exactly. This is that, that,
so this is 20,000 years old underneath
this. Yeah, that's right. Wow.
And what,
what can we,
is there any images that we could look
at or is there anything that we could see
other than this? Um, well
I have a lot in the book.
I know she went out the image above it.
That's an artist's rendition to look like
that's an absolute artist's rendition,
which I don't value. It's it, it, it, it
almost takes the form of misinformation.
We need to be looking at the real thing.
Berries at bet. Now there that painting,
you have your cursor just on it,
just Greg on that.
That is an artist's interpretation of
what Gunung Padang would have looked like
in its original 20,000 years
ago before it became overgrown.
But that is the mind blower.
Then if this 20,000 years ago,
if this actually exists to this gigantic
megalithic structure that was created
by human beings,
advanced civilization beyond a
shadow of a doubt 20,000 years ago,
and it's a deal in an area that was
devastated by the global floods of 12,800
years ago and that became a completely
different from how it was before.
Before that.
What was the area that had that gigantic
super volcano detonation 70,000 years
ago, but that's another Indonesian store
and that is Indonesia and that that is
literally where
a massive amount of the population of
the earth of human beings was wiped out.
May of 70 the human population went
down to just 2000 individual cheese.
That's like a good comedy show for me.
Like a theater can imagine that everyone
in my show repopulate the fucking
earth.
Sometimes our species hangs by a thread.
Sometimes we hang by a thread
that that was one of those times.
See that is crazy.
The idea that just the earth can have a
hiccup and that's not even an asteroid.
That's the earth itself.
That's up. Belching.
Belches destroys the environment to
the point where it creates nuclear.
Winter kills all the crops.
Most of the animals die and 2000
people scratch and claw their way,
the existence. Wow. And
only 70,000 years ago,
so 50,000 years before this,
so 50,000 so there's been
a series of these. Yes,
there've been a series of these and we
as a species of kind of dawn [inaudible]
in and out of them and from time to time
they have radically changed our story,
our Hubris in creating drives,
hard drives and flash drives and
computers and phones and no one remembers
anything. I can, I maybe know
for phone numbers, you know,
we don't,
we don't use the power of memory anymore
and we don't write anything down and,
and anything that's going to survive
any sort of a disaster. Yeah, yeah,
absolutely.
That's where the systems
like free masonry command,
because here you have a body of symbolism
that's been handed down at least since
the Middle Ages. And you
have a lot of, you know,
currently active masons who in order to
become master masons have to memorize a
tremendous amount of information.
Most of them don't have a clue
as to what it means though,
even though they're told right into
ritual. If you want to understand this,
you have to understand astronomy.
First of all,
you have to understand geometry and
a number of other things. But, um,
a tremendous amount of,
of memory work is involved.
And this is the ancient system,
the oral traditions involved
memory on a massive scale,
being able to recite verbatim things
that might take you hours to recite.
And we, like you guys have just
discussed, we were losing that ability.
And, and this is, you know, to me it's,
it's regrettable that freemasonry has
gotten such a bad rep with all of these
silly conspiratorial things in the last,
in the age of the Internet.
I got to tell you how many times on
Facebook or the Internet, somebody,
and they expressed it as, as
an accusation. Yeah. Graham
Hancock is a Freemason.
Well, first off, I'm not a free mason.
I've never been a free mason and I never
will be a free mason because I'm not a
joiner. I don't join clubs. My, my
job is to write books. And if I,
if I join a particular club that's going
to compromise my ability to do that.
I have given lectures in masonic lodges.
I've been invited to give
lectures there. And I, I'm,
I'm very interested to talk to
Mason's, but, uh, you know, I'm not,
I'm not amazing myself.
And it is strange that there is
this idea that free masonry is,
is connected to some kind
of global conspiracy.
I think it's much more complicated and
much more interesting than that. Well,
it's a, an ancient, like, as you said,
and an ancient way of sort of storing
and passing down knowledge and ideas.
I mean, I'm sure there's a bunch of
wacky people that are involved in it too.
Most of them are in it for them.
Frank Beer,
not freemasonry is
largely a male drinking.
Maybe I'm in then maybe I need to
find these people. Well, actually,
maybe that's in the UK. In the US,
there's no drinking in the lodge.
The lodge is not even the lodge itself,
but, but afterwards, okay, I'm out.
It was a lot of alcohol goes
down. I was in, I'm now I'm out.
Well, yeah, drinking does
mess with your memory though.
So I see that there is a tremendous
body of symbolism in there,
which I think is critical to understanding
a lot of these ancient mysteries.
How's ancient origins? One of the things
that's so confusing about our money,
right? And so conspiratorially, uh,
constantly debated about the origins of
the symbolism on our money. You know,
the pyramid with the
eye ball on top of it.
And there's so many theories as to
what this means and that means, and Oh,
look at the way they structured
from Washington DC and
where the Pentagon is and
where all these different buildings are
all zoll mason stuff and they want to
take over the world. And Yeah, I dunno,
but it's a who knows really basket.
I think what's important about it is that
it's a system of ideas that definitely
has very ancient origins, which we're
seeing a modern manifestation of it now.
But it tracks back a
long way into the past.
And this shows that the ideas
can be passed down below
the radar and can survive
and can continue. Well the, the
eyeball on top of the pyramid, man,
I would love to go back to the dude
who created the dollar bill and go,
what are you doing?
And what the fuck is that?
How come you just don't say $1 and have
the have the dude's face and we're good.
Right? Why do you have to have a
pyramid with an eye ball? Yeah.
Like what does that mean?
What a wonder what it meant to them?
What is it supposed to symbolize?
I think it means the same thing
to admit to the ancient Egyptians.
We find the eye of Horus
Egyptian.
Doesn't the eye of Horus
represent the pineal gland?
That's a good argument. Yeah.
It actually looks like the
pineal gland from a side profile.
It looks exactly like it
looks like it. And, and um,
we know that a DMT was
available in nature in Egypt,
but the ancient Egyptian tree
of life is occasionally Latika,
which is rich in DMT in
its, in its box. Well,
that's also the tree that
they're considering the the
modern Jerusalem scholars
have attached to Moses
and the burning Bush,
the burning Bush being the source of
divinity or the source of, of God,
of divine knowledge,
God being a burning Bush and
that Bush being the Acacia tree,
Acacia tree being rich and DMT.
I mean,
it only makes sense if you try to break
it down and translate it, if that,
if anybody who's done DMT knows what a
profound and life changing experience it
can be and how there is
this feeling when you do it,
that you are connecting to some
sort of divine entity. Well,
we have to look at this image. Okay,
should I go you at Jamie, put it up there.
Well,
it's a typical,
you find this in all kinds of masonic
that's spooky to do and given a a haircut.
Well,
he's going to wanes.
You see what you have
here is a juxtaposition of
different symbols and they all
have an interpretation. Bright.
You see the old man father time,
but he holds the sick father.
Time also has wings. Two wings,
wings well applies.
What time flies. Flies.
Well, I dare you. You notice
notice the Hourglass, right? Okay.
The hourglass by the cycle and the
cycle is a symbol for the comment.
I'm going to go ahead and
a calmness bill some. Yes,
I can show you how that works.
You know the word comment
comes from the Latin Cometa or
come eat done, which means what
long hair, right? Oh Randal.
Long hair had star actually
looks a bit like a company.
So as you're looking at the star in
the sky and you see the tail, they,
they think of that as the
hair of the con. Yes, exactly.
So what you have there is the long hair
right there. That's a signal right there.
That as a reference, and I can show
you a couple of other things to show.
The time was going bald.
What's all that about? Yeah.
Well he's making up for it
was the whiskers. Yeah. Um,
but you'll notice what she
holds in her right hand,
the sprig of Acacia once you hold it.
And so in,
in the masonic symbolism,
Acacia represents resurrection.
Rec represents restoration.
After in the masonic allegory,
you have the,
the death of the master builder and
the raising of the master builder.
And the symbolism for this,
whether it ultimately,
I think goes back to the death and
resurrection of a Cyrus and the death and
resurrection of all of these
God figures in history,
which could be taking in resurrecting
gods, the diamond, the resurrecting gods,
which could be taken as a metaphor really
for the god standing in for the human
species for human civilization.
And she's, she's actually weeping.
She's holding in her
left hand a Cyborg IOM,
which was a symbol from
alchemy in the Masonic Sansi.
It's in that container that she's
holding that the alchemy takes place,
which you might speculate is maybe the
extraction of the DMT from the occasions.
What I was gonna say, it looks almost like
one of those incents holders. You know,
you put the, you get an incense cone,
you put it in, you put the lid on that,
and the incense comes through that,
right.
And she's looking at a book and
she's looking at a book, right?
And then the book is sitting on a
broken column, the broken column.
Uh, actually that what that represents
is very well depicted in this next image
here,
which was basically the loss,
the destruction of the lost civilization.
And that's what she's weeping overseas.
She's holding the occasion because
that's the symbol of Resurrection, right?
How civilization is then renewed Phoenix,
like out of the ashes of the
previous one out of drugs.
Maybe assistant maybe with some
assistance will help. Yeah. So,
so you see there and then you and you
go back to this, see, it's all there.
And once you begin to understand
that the symbolism of this,
you can begin to read it just like a,
a book or a manuscript almost.
You see?
And there we see it a 19th
century depiction of, you know,
the destruction of civilization
by coming by a comment.
Yes. And absolutely
fascinating. Yeah. Yeah.
It's interesting stuff. Um, boy,
there's a lot of work in that,
you know,
is this a universal description,
like the way or interpretation
of what you're saying is,
has everyone agree on
that? No. No, no. In fact,
basically most of more look at it and
really not really understand the law.
That's pretty what in
many different cultures,
a calm it is the long haired
Star it looks like on Saturday.
And sometimes it's the cosmic serpent,
sometimes it's a sip and
sometimes it's a serpent. Yeah,
it looks like an old dude that's creeping
on. A young girl was trying to read
like, you know, she's trying to read,
he's trying to give her a back massage
and just trying to be kind of being
creepy, but it looks like
[inaudible]. Good. Well here we have,
this is a 19th century masonic carpet.
Now you'll notice several things on here.
What do you see up on the right?
A comment. A comment, yes.
And immediately to the left of the comic
you have a Lunar Crescent and then you
have the seven stars. And what does the
seven stars usually depict? The Pleiades?
Yeah, part of the Taurus
constellation. Exactly. Yeah.
And if you superimpose the radiant of the
Taurid meteor shower almost bolts eyes
right on the right on the Pleiades,
and you find the Pleiades playing an
important part in not only the masonic
ritual,
but in many traditions,
additions there even clearly depicted in
the hall of bulls in Lascaux in France
17,000 years ago at depiction of the
constellation of tourists with the plate,
he's clearly marked on the
shoulder of the, of the bull.
So anybody who argues that there was
no ancient knowledge of the Zodiacal
constellations, go to Lascaux
and you'll realize there was.
Wow. And you'll notice
down here there's the arc,
which of course is
symbolizing the great flood.
And you've got a lot of
things going on here.
You've got the coffin with the
occasion growing out of it,
which again is symbolizing this
resurrection after the death.
So that one plant plays an important
role over and over and over.
Those are very important role.
It doesn't mean it can't be
coincidental that the road, that day
planning human culture has been radically
underestimated and misunderstood by,
by, uh, our scholars.
Is there any depictions in the
ancient world of utilization, of DMT,
of smoking, it, of,
there's many depictions of,
of the ancient Egyptian and ancient
Egyptian figure holding some kind of pipe.
Uh, and now that we know that occasionally
Latika is a DMT rich tree and that the
ancient Egyptians certainly had the
chemical knowledge to extract the DMT from
that bark. The very word
chemistry actually comes from
the name of ancient Egypt,
which was Kemet the black land. That's
where we get the word chemistry from.
We can be pretty sure what
they were smoking. Um,
there is a particular scene by the way,
where we see another visionary, um, agent.
The datura plant,
um,
raise in the form of Datura flowers
are descending into the brow,
into the third eye of the
initiative in, in, in that image.
The imagery is all there.
You just have to dig it out
and look for it and find it,
look for it with eyes that are willing
to see. That's the crucial thing.
I've never seen the, uh, hieroglyphs
of them holding a pipe. Oh yeah.
There's, there's maybe a funny
Jeremy, do you see any? Yeah.
Wow. So what are we looking
at here, Randall? Oh,
just another version of
these old masonic carpets,
but the thing that you'd
want to look at here,
what the beehive thing in the
lower left hand corner there. Yeah.
That seems to be over and over again.
You see over and over again. Yeah.
Why a beehive? Is it a beehive?
Beehive? Yeah, it is. So it does it.
Is it supposed to represent
like beekeeping and is a
form of I will agriculture
or I'll fill you in on that someday.
These were a symbol of
royalty in ancient Egypt.
You find them all over the
temple of conic for example,
one of the masonic context.
It has a very interesting connotation
which would be probably beyond what we
could get into another show.
It's another whole nother show on bees.
Does it? I mean what, what
I mean when you look at,
well it's one of the main concerns that
we have today is that our cell phone
signals and a lot of the pesticides
that we're using are killing off bees.
Okay.
The cell phone signals are apparently
like really confusing bees and messing
them up and the Wifi and all the waves,
radio waves and different things in
the atmosphere interfere with their
communication. But then on top of that,
the pesticides we're putting on crops,
all these, and then there's
diseases that bees are getting.
And we have a serious problem with
the honeybee population. I know.
And to have that as a big
part of their culture,
to have bees is a big part of their
culture, says something. Yeah.
You know what your superficially told
in the masonic ritual is that bees are a
symbol of industry,
but when you're being in to look into it,
the beehive itself is interesting
architecturally. Right? You know,
because what it does,
it has the maximum volume to weight
ratio virtually have any structure,
but there's other considerations there as
well, which again is a, is another show.
But if you look carefully
right up in here,
you'll notice there's a
twin comet twin stars.
You see the tails and you'll notice
that you, you know, that comets,
their tails are always
pointing away from the sun.
They're not like trails behind
like the wake of a boat.
They're pointing away from the sun.
You see? And if you look at this,
you see you've got the sun right here
and you've got these moving away.
The heart is a symbol for the earth.
The sword is another symbol
for the comment. Okay.
So all of us, wow. All of this mystery,
uh, s, uh, surrounds us and, and,
and,
and all of it takes us back to a time
that we've forgotten and we need to know
about that time. We need to, we need
to recover our memory. The, the, the,
the human species is in a kind
of broken state right now. Uh,
psychologically you can see
it in the world. There's a,
there's this miasma of hatred and fear
and suspicion that are just enveloping
the whole world.
And we are being divided artificially
from one another when Trudy,
we are all brothers and sisters.
And we need to recover that knowledge
if we're to move forward to the future.
And on that note, I also want to
thank you for another thing, Joe,
which is for smoking me up last
re-introducing marijuana.
I had three years of abstinence from
marijuana and that abstinence ended,
uh, when we sat down for our
last chat, September, 2014.
Well you seem so healthy. I'm like,
I don't think pods the problem. No,
it's not the problem.
I am.
What's happened is I've completely changed
my relationship to that beautiful and
magical herb.
It's not a dependent relationship anymore.
It's not an obsessional relationship. If
I have it, I enjoy it. If I don't have it,
I enjoy my life anyway.
That's beautiful. Yeah.
I have a friend who was a drug counselor
and last time he was telling me his
story is also a comedian. And last time
he was telling me a story court court,
McGowan great guy. And he was telling
me a story about this kid that is a,
that he's trying to
help that what he said.
I had never met a marijuana
addict for and uh,
he met this kid and this kid
was smoking just massive,
massive amounts of marijuana.
He's trying to help him in his clinic
and he realized along the way, it's not,
it has nothing to do with the marijuana.
Like he's got some crazy psychological
issue that's going on and the marijuana
just happens to be the thing he's using
to try to fill up to medicate that.
It's not that he has this physical
addiction that's impossible to,
there is no physical addiction.
If the marijuana wasn't there,
he'd find something else.
Yes, that's what it is.
And then when he dug deep into it,
this poor kid has just a devastating
childhood and there's all sorts of issues.
Psychological, it was the case
with addiction. It's the, it's,
it's the pain in the individual that's
the source of it, not the substance.
That's, I think we can all relate
to a certain amount of madness.
And I know I certainly can because I think
we all capable of going down. You Bet.
Spirals and pass and then you know that
the concept of hitting rock bottom,
like sometimes you have to like hit
something where you can't continue your
momentum and you must regroup.
And in that regrouping,
you reassess or reevaluate and it's one
of the reasons why I'm so addicted to
sensory deprivation tanks because
that's my regrouping. It's an amazing,
it's an amazing place to regroup and thank
you for introducing me to that. Uh, as,
as,
as as well.
I am so grateful that there's people
out there that have continued that
tradition of building those things from
the Samadhi tanks from the early sixties,
from John Lilly to today crashed
and the float lab and, and,
and the zero gravity in Austin.
I mean,
they've done some amazing work and making
sure these things are like uptodate
and the most,
uh,
the most modern technology as far as
filtration systems and installation.
And now they're magical. I mean,
absolutely. You went to crash, right?
Plastic, fantastic
experience. I have to say,
I'm really thinking about putting one of
those in my house. It, everybody should.
I mean, God, man, you
know, that's the way to it. That's
the way it is, the way to it.
And to enjoy the experience to the maximum
to get the maximum benefit out of the
experience and intensely
intensely psychedelic without
adult edibles. Exactly.
I'm, I'm really encouraged by
what's happening in America,
that we are seeing the
legalization of cannabis,
that the American people state by state
are just putting their finger up to this
federal authority and
saying we are adults.
We have a right to decide what we
do with our own bodies and our own
consciousness.
And there is that air of freedom now in,
in Washington state and
Oregon up there in Alaska,
Colorado. And, and that's,
so this is part of my book tour that
I'm really looking forward to when I go
present an event in Seattle, which I'll
do in early December and in Portland,
Oregon and in Denver and in boulder.
I'm a Denver Saturday night.
I couldn't be more excited to get there.
I was so pumped.
I can't wait to get there.
And it's a great place.
It's a point of freedom and it's also
a point of prosperity. Yes. Denver has,
they have exceeded their,
their what?
They had it in terms of like their
expectations for how much money they were
going to make out of this
in terms of tax revenue.
It's gone through the roof is the first
time ever they make more money from
taxes and marijuana. Then alcohol
exact, which is fucking crazy.
You go around Colorado,
you see how many bars there are,
how many liquor stores and the
restaurants are serving booze.
They make more money in taxes from
marijuana. They do from all of that,
let's face it, Mary one is a far
superior substance to our call.
I'll call the horrible place.
It's not hurting.
The booze is not heading the boost
business. Yeah, violent crime is down.
Drunk driving is the lowest level.
It's been a decade.
I mean the whole thing is inquisitive,
very positive story real has coming up.
Colorado is proving to the world is that
the emperor of the war on drugs wears
no clothes.
The war on drugs is bullshit.
It is from beginning to end and it's a
grotesque abuse of the right of adults to
make decisions about their own
bodies and their own consciousness.
So right on with Colorado and the
American people who are making this happen
only in America could this
breakthrough take place.
It's true that America as a state entity
has been a dark force behind the war on
drugs,
but the American people state by state
are unraveling that horror and replacing
it with something new.
This could never happen in Britain.
I mean we have counties in Britain
like Yorkshire or Northumberland.
I can't envisage a situation ever where
Yorkshire would make marijuana legal
when London says no,
but in America you can do it and this
is going to change the world. It's not.
It's not because of marijuana itself.
That's not the point.
It's not about getting high.
It's about respecting the rights of
adults to make decisions about their own
bodies, their own health
and their own consciousness.
That is a fundamental human right and
we're beginning to realize that that's
exactly what's been taken away
from us by the war on drugs.
I think it's also about making
decisions based on data.
And I think in a way that parallels
what you guys are up to. Yeah.
Because I think people are
understanding now that we, we've been
sold a bill of goods by these so
called experts about marijuana.
They've told us so many long nonsense.
And not only that,
the politicians have hired experts to
review the data and then buried it when it
did meet your expectations.
Yes,
exactly.
Well,
I have to confess that all of this with
me started back in the old days when I
was camping in these canyon lands
into Western states and altering my
consciousness and looking at the landscape
and going, something is going on here.
There's a story here that is
wanting to come out and you know,
you can,
I think that you have the Ph.
We have the potential literally to
almost time travel with some of these
substances and peer into the past and
see it in ways that we would have never
seen otherwise. Um, and then
not literally, but like get
a, a sense of your mind.
He knew perspective,
a fresh view.
You were talking about it the last time
you were here that you were on acid.
Right?
That's what it was.
I said in Payoti mostly the
children of this little bit of that,
but yeah, yeah. Spending, you know, a lot
of time out, you know, hiking and camping,
you know,
from,
from Minnesota to the Pacific Ocean and
all those Northwestern states. You know,
I spent months out there, you know,
just hanging in the landscape, you know,
living in, in, in tents up
on mountain tops and, and,
and thinking about what was
I seeing, you know, and um,
that's really where it started for me.
And I think that combining, combining,
you know,
this immersion into the landscape,
you're talking about
the sensory deprivation,
which is a way to powerfully go in.
At the same time,
you can have the counterpart of that
which is powerfully going out and seeing,
seeing the night sky
in this altered state,
seeing the landscapes around you and
realizing that a heel isn't just a hill.
There's a story there.
There's,
there's some process that
we have to come to come to,
to reckon with in order to understand
this planet we're living on.
There's an interesting point here,
which is the part of the
technological world is to regard, uh,
nature as a matter as dead. You'd know
that there's just this dead [inaudible].
We're the only consciousness on
the planet in the, in the universe.
And they will refuse to consider the
possibility that nature may be highly
conscious and highly intelligent,
but there may be intelligence in nature.
And it seems to me what
the psychedelics are,
are nature's way of speaking to us
when we've closed our minds and shut
ourselves down when we've taken the soul
out of the universe and just turned it
into a huge machine, the psychedelics
are coming back and saying,
hang on you monkeys.
I don't know everything. Listen
to us. We got something to teach.
And with that we just ran through three
hours. Yeah, that's it. How crazy is that?
Those three hours?
It seems like it's 20 minutes.
It was probably more than three hours,
right? We overtime we're over. Uh, listen,
thank you so much, Graham.
Hancock, magicians of the gods.
You can get it right now on, what is
your website again? Graham hancock.com.
Graham hancock.com. Sacred Geometry
International. Sacred geometry.
I. N. T I believe is your Twitter handle?
Is that what it is? I think that's right.
Um, I'll check right now real quick. Yes.
Sacred geometry. Just sacred geo. Sacred.
G. O. I. N. T. Okay. And
Randall, thank you so much.
Knowing double underscore between the
grass. Well, you could find it folks.
If you go to my Twitter page,
it'll be on my Twitter page.
You could find both of their,
uh,
their Twitter handles on the post that
we made about this. Let's do this again.
Can we do this again?
Absolutely. I'm a port.
Let's do it again in a couple
of months. Fantastic. All Right,
ladies and gentlemen, thank you
very much. We'll see you soon. Joe.
I would like to keep you out,
okay.
Okay.